each member speaking will be allotted 10
minutes for debate followed by 10
minutes for questions and comments
pursuant to the order made earlier today
the time provided for the debate may be
extended beyond four hours as needed to
include a minimum of 16 periods of 20
minutes each members may divide their
time with another member of the
of the chair
sorry and the chair will receive no
quorum calls dilatory motions or
requests for unanimous consent
take note of russia's attack on ukraine
debate
the right honorable prime minister
[Applause]
i will be speaking today i'll be sharing
my
have civil defense sirens that date back
to world war ii
some test them every month some every
year
but when sirens went off in kv kharkiv
and other cities in ukraine last week
it wasn't a drill
ukraine
is under attack
the sound of war
reverberates throughout the whole world
the canadian government has long
condemned russia's incursion into
ukraine
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity must be respected
and ukrainian people must be free to
determine their own future
mr speaker this invasion is unjust
unprovoked
and illegal
and as i said before
russia will
be held accountable
for
is
as well as
is being inspired by ukrainians who
remain strong
and resilient
everyday people are bravely stepping up
to defend their country
but despite their extraordinary courage
we can't forget
the devastating human consequences of
war
three days ago i received an email from
a ukrainian canadian who lives in
calgary
he told me he had relatives and friends
who were taking cover in basements
trying to avoid the shelling
over this past week i've received many
letters like this one
we've all seen the images of subway
stations being used as bomb shelters
of missiles striking apartment buildings
of families including young children
leaving everything behind
in search of somewhere safe
the cost of war is always
incalculable
but in these dark hours
canada will continue to be resolute
in its support for ukraine
foreign
we will continue
ukrainian
president
when i was in ukraine in 2016 the many
people i met showed me how much they
loved their country and how hard they
had fought for democracy
listening to them
reminded me of how peace and stability
is not something we could
or should
ever take for granted
now with the unfolding tragedy in
ukraine the whole world is reminded once
again
just how fragile peace can be
mr speaker in the shadow of
authoritarianism we here know that the
path forward is the rule of law
universal values and freedom
that's why canadians
members of this house stand united with
ukraine
democracies everywhere stand together we
stand with the people around the globe
protesting against this brutal war from
vancouver to montreal from berlin to
prague from minsk to moscow and saint
petersburg
we hear their voices and we all hope
they will overcome the sound
of sirens and bombs
thank you
slava ukraine
questions
[Applause]
questions and comments questions
the honourable member for barry
innesville thank you uh mr speaker i
want to thank the prime minister for his
words this evening one of the things
that canadians are talking about a lot
and we've been discussing it throughout
the course of today is the need for
energy independence energy security in
this country whether it's liquefied
natural gas whether it's natural
resource production making sure that
this country our canada is energy secure
i'm wondering if the prime minister can
speak to the events that have happened
in russia and the need to secure energy
in this country thank you mr speaker the
right honorable prime minister
mr speaker over the past number of weeks
we've been working closely with our
allies in europe who indeed are
dependent to a large degree on imports
of energy from russia and are right now
in a difficult position
that is why we are so touched by the
steadfastness and the strength of the
european response
in
putting severe sanctions on russia even
though
there is uncertainty in terms of their
energy security and i have assured them
uh that canada and countries around the
world will be there to support them as
they move forward canada is a producer
and exporter of energy we have banned as
of today any imports which were already
negligible from russia of uh or crude
oil but we will continue to work with
the world to make sure that we can stand
strongly against russia and support
people in democracies everywhere
[Applause]
go
is this something we're going to need
foreign
questions and comments the honourable
member for burnaby south
thank you mr speaker we are witnessing a
humanitarian crisis unfolding in ukraine
with bombings and attacks and casualties
so canada must do its part as countries
around the world are stepping up one of
the things we can do is learn from the
past where there were significant
problems with welcoming people in
emergency crisis and i looked to
afghanistan as an example of what not to
do where we failed ensuring the safety
of our allies to get to canada so when
will the prime minister ensure that we
have a visa free
barrier-free access to canada for
ukrainians who are seeking refuge in
this time of crisis
the right honorable prime minister mr
speaker in the weeks leading up to this
terrible last week we've had
canada was already positioning itself
in case the worse which did come to pass
came to pass our immigration ministry
and minister have been working hard to
ensure more resources
for
treatment of requests to come to canada
opportunities to accelerate uh the
treatments of of of uh work permits uh
to canada uh opportunities to stretch
out the permits of those who are here
now and most importantly to make sure
we're able to take in as many ukrainians
who are fleeing uh the violence as
possible to be able to settle in canada
to hunker down uh while this passes or
perhaps even as so many ukrainians have
over so many generations choosing to
stay for good in canada we know uh
canada has been extraordinarily enriched
by canadians of ukrainian heritage and
we will continue to be there to welcome
in ukrainians to build a better life for
themselves here but also back home in
ukraine
resuming debate
the honorable minister of national
defense
[Applause]
mr speaker putin's actions over the past
week are appalling for all of us who
stand for peace
security and democracy
i would like to send my very best to
president zielenski minister reznikov
and the ukrainian people for their
strong resistance against putin's
ruthless aggression and unnecessary war
[Applause]
[Music]
is a direct threat not only to the
people of ukraine but also to global
safety and stability mr speaker
in the face of this brutal assault on
the ukrainian people our support for
ukraine is unwavering
canada
canada
we have provided lethal and non-lethal
equipment to bolster their defenses
canada has pledged millions of dollars
in defensive military equipment to
ukraine
first 23 million dollars delivered since
2015.
second
10 million dollars delivered earlier
this month including sniper rifles and
ammunition
third just yesterday
minister jolie and i announced an
additional 25 million in non-lethal aid
including night vision gear helmets body
armor
these items have been specifically
requested by the ukrainian government
and we are stepping up to meet their
needs alongside our allies
now to support the delivery of aid and
to contribute to nato efforts in europe
canada is also providing two c-130j
tactical airlift aircraft
for a minimum of two weeks
one of these aircraft departed canada
for europe today
and the other will follow later this
week
and at the request of ukraine and in
coordination with nato allies we
announced today
that we are committing additional
lethal aid to ukraine
including at least
100 anti-tank weapon systems and 2 000
rockets
which are working to deliver as quickly
as possible in the coming days
the canadian armed forces has delivered
well over 700 training sessions
throughout operation unifier
canada's military training mission in
ukraine and in addition
we have 3 400 soldiers at the ready in
case they are called up by nato to serve
for our alliance in a defensive and
deterrent posture mr speaker
canada is not alone in this mission to
help ukraine nato allies are more united
than ever the world has become a
dangerous place and while these dangers
can feel far away to canadians these are
tumultuous times and we must unite as a
country and redouble our efforts to
support our allies we stand with the
people of ukraine we will continue to
support them in the face of unwarranted
russian aggression
thank you thank you
questions and comments just come out
there the honourable member for selkirk
interlake eastman thank you mr speaker
and i want to thank the minister of
defense for her speech and for her
support of ukraine and and uh for the
announcement today of providing
some anti-tank missiles and more ammo
which the
ukrainian military needs desperately
and i know that um you know minister
we've been
putting pressure on you for some time to
do this and and i think it was back in
2018 when conservatives first said that
we could take the uh weapons that were
originally destined for the kurdish
peshmerga to be sent over to help
ukraine which included anti-tank
missiles at that time
now on in addition to to to the
announcement today i'd like to know what
type of time frame uh mode administer
when those uh will actually get
delivered and
how soon uh are they going to be either
procured here uh in north america are
they coming from existing inventory that
we have in canada and uh you know
ultimately uh how do we get more of them
to help ukraine in their battle against
the russian federation
the honorable minister
i thank my honorable colleague for the
question and i must say it is heartening
to see um
politics put aside in times of crisis
and i will say in response to his
questions directly
we are working to get this lethal aid
in the hands of ukrainian soldiers as
soon as possible and in order to do that
we are working very closely with our
allies to ensure safe passage of the
lethal aid as well as safe delivery to
the canadian armed forces and to
ukrainian soldiers as well and in terms
of his question relating to the
inventory itself
the lethal aid that we have announced
today does come from existing inventory
and i will continue to reiterate that
all hands are on deck we are continuing
to ensure that we are responding as
quickly as possible to the requests of
the ukrainian government my
conversations with minister resnikov
over the past number of weeks have been
instrumental in allowing us to know
precisely what it is that ukraine needs
and how we can best deliver it to them
thank you mr speaker questions and
comments questions
questions and comments
resilience and courage it's
unprecedented
so we need to be
ukrainians who have fled in
collaboration with the neighboring
countries
[Music]
which is very important
foreign
[Music]
questions and comments the honourable
member for couch in malahat langford a
30-second question hopefully a 30-second
answer yes thank you mr speaker during
this conflict we have seen the russian
army direct intentional attacks against
civilians and civilian targets i want to
know mr speaker how is the canadian
government documenting these possible
crimes and how will we work with our
allies to make sure that russian
military commanders and their civilian
oversight are held to account after this
conflict so they don't escape justice
the honorable minister of defense in 30
seconds or less please
uh mr speaker i thank the honourable
member for his question
we know that these attacks cyber attacks
included are part of the russian
playbook we have been watching russian
escalation at the ukrainian border for
months and months and we are very well
prepared in terms of our intelligence
and connections with the ukrainian
government
to document the loss of life more
important however
is making sure that we are stepping up
with humanitarian and economic aid and
ensuring safe passage for ukrainians as
they leave ukraine and we are doing all
three mr speaker we have provided over
700 million dollars worth of economic
and humanitarian aid thus far alone and
we are also ensuring safe passage for
ukrainians as they leave their country
thank you
resuming debate
the honorable leader of the opposition
[Applause]
these are painful and heartbreaking days
for the people of ukraine
it's unbelievable to watch images of
families fleeing the violence of
citizens volunteering lining up to
receive weapons to fight for their
country and of parents sending their
children away to safety while they stay
behind to defend ukraine
in the last few days the world has seen
the defiance and strength of ukrainians
standing up for their freedom
independence and sovereignty against the
unprovoked aggression of a violent
dictator
their voices were joined by millions of
people here in canada and around the
world
including thousands of russians who took
to the streets to oppose the war many of
them dragged away to prison
as the official opposition conservatives
stand shoulder to shoulder with ukraine
and its people and we condemn putin and
his gang in the strongest and harshest
terms possible
putin's ongoing invasion of ukraine is
the first major european conflict since
the second world war it is a serious
violation of both international law and
our collective humanity
this amounts to the most serious threat
to the rules-based international order
since 1945 and because of that it is a
serious threat to global peace and
security that's why conservatives fully
support the actions taken by the
government of canada thus far
but we are calling on the liberals to do
more
on saturday we released our proposals
for immediate additional action and i
would like to outline them for the
members tonight
first we are urging the federal
government to expel russians ambassador
from canada right away
second we are asking the government to
recall canada's ambassador from moscow
thirdly we ask the the government to
direct the crtc to revoke the license of
russia today so that putin's propaganda
machine can no longer reach canadian
homes we are glad that companies like
rogers tell us bell and shaw have
already done this but we would like to
see the federal government take more of
a lead on this issue
fourthly we believe russia should be
isolated internationally by urging their
removal from organizations like the g20
and the osce
and fifth we would like to encourage the
government to implement visa-free travel
from ukraine to canada to help families
escape here for to safety
the ukrainian people do not want to be
permanent refugees they want to be able
to live in a free peaceful and sovereign
ukraine
but canada can be a safe haven for them
in this moment
they can serve it to a pre-left
conservative
russian asian threat
international
global security news
canadian government
yes
speaker the liberal government can't
afford to take our peace and security
for granted any longer we need to take
putin's threats seriously
we need to make sure canada is prepared
to face aggression with the same level
of determination we've seen in the
ukrainian people
that's why conservatives are calling on
the government to come forward with a
robust plan to defend canada's arctic
security and sovereignty
this includes modernizing norad's early
warning system
it's also time that we fix canada's long
broken military procurement system
we must accelerate the national
shipbuilding program and finally it's
time to purchase f-35 jets
[Applause]
we need to work in closer cooperation
with scandinavian allies and the united
states to ensure canada's north remains
canada's liberals have ignored our
arctic for six years and this russian
invasion of ukraine should be a wake-up
call to get serious about canada's
arctic
mr speaker russians ongoing invasion of
ukraine has highlighted another serious
problem
russia supplies as much as 40 percent of
europe's natural gas
and we're seeing them use this power to
intimidate europeans and
ukrainians if supplies are cut
people can't heat their homes
entire industries will collapse and
europe's gdp will plummet
canada has the answer here
canada is the world's fifth largest
natural gas producer
but we can't export gas to our european
allies because we can't get pipelines
built
the liberal government has failed
repeatedly to recognize the canadian oil
and gas is the most most ethical
most environmentally responsible oil and
gas industry in the
than world mr speaker that canada's oil
and gas is vital to the security and
sovereignty of both canada and europe
it's clearer than ever that when the
liberals stop delay and hamstring
canadian oil and gas from being
extracted transported and sold both at
home and abroad the biggest winner in
every way shape and form is putin
canada and the world loses and putin
wins why in the world would we want to
do anything to help putin for fund his
war chest
the liberals need to stop putting up
roadblocks to oil and gas development
and exports we need to get new pipelines
built so that we can sell our energy to
europe and others and end russia's
monopoly on natural gas
mr speaker for over a century canadians
of ukraine descent have enriched our
communities and our culture especially
in the prairies where i am from
canada and manitoba in particular share
ties with ukraine that cannot be broken
by war and aggression
when ukraine declared independence from
the soviet union three decades ago it
was canada under a conservative prime
minister that was the first country to
recognize its sovereignty
we must honor that legacy as canadian
parliamentarians i know we honor that
legacy
[Applause]
cannabis security is tied to europe and
conservatives know that
canada must strengthen our own defenses
and renew our commitment to the nato
alliance in the face of the threats from
both russia and china
as we speak tonight mr speaker ukrainian
families are huddled in subway stations
calling for our help
just as the british did during the blitz
over eight decades ago
a country that faced the horrors of the
stalin regime with the holdemore but
nonetheless emerged from the grasp of
communist dictators is again
fighting off tyranny and violence we
must stand with them the federal
government has stepped up in the last
few days but there is more that can be
done
as they say in ukraine
ukraine glory to ukraine glory to the
heroes
but let's do more than just say those
words
let's take action now and in the days
and the months to come to do the right
thing for ukraine
for canadians
and indeed for the world thank you very
much
[Applause]
questions and comments the honourable
member for parkdale high park thank you
very much mr speaker and i thank the
interim leader of the opposition for
those important remarks and for the
demonstration of unity that we've seen
in this chamber on such a pressing
global issue i know that in my riding in
toronto
in manitoba right around the country
we've seen canadians of all backgrounds
all demographics coming forward and
standing up for democracy against
russian aggression calling out for what
we need from this parliament and we've
seen some of that delivered even just
today with the addition of additional
lethal munitions and lethal armaments to
assist ukraine in defending its own
sovereignty
but they've also talked to people like
me who represent ukrainian canadians and
to others in this chamber about a
distinct type of threat that is emerging
which is a threat of cyber security and
cyber threats i wonder if we could have
uh the leader of the interim leader of
the opposition's comments on how do we
combat this pernicious threat in terms
of the online world where cyber threats
are festering and if her party will work
with our party in combating this
including with combating what exists
online and how to getting getting tough
with these kinds of important cyber
threats thank you the honorable leader
of the opposition thank you very much
and i do want to thank my colleague for
that question and indeed cyber security
is a threat that has been a reality for
a number of years i know when we were in
government i was parliamentary secretary
for public safety and we were talking
about it at that time that it was almost
it's a new theater of war uh the cyber
security and and and the threats that
come certainly from from putin from
countries like russia but also countries
like china
i think that's why it's so important
that we move forward quickly to ban
huawei
i think that there are immediate threats
that we have to take seriously that we
as a as a country working together with
our allies
listening to our allies listening to our
other our allies for example who've
already booked the ban wall way
that's something practically that we can
do but certainly we recognize the threat
uh that there is and i you know i think
the other thing in all of this
discussion that we should be recognizing
we talk about russia and the russian
threat but let's be clear this is a
threat from putin that there's millions
i would say of russian people in russia
and around the world who do not support
what putin is doing
just as as saddened heartbroken and
probably terrified at what this dictator
is doing so i thank my colleague for
that question and i i just wanted to
make sure that that was on the record as
well thank you
questions and comments questions
uh
well i appreciate that question and you
know i i agree in some ways it is it is
symbolic but in our in our
in our world order it is it is an
important symbolic uh gesture and actual
action to make to send an ambassador
home and recall one's ambassador it
sends a strong message uh that that the
the country and the leader of that
country in this case russia is being
isolated
i do not believe we can
negotiate with putin i don't think
diplomacy works with him i think that's
been very clear so uh you know to answer
that for that that member's question um
yeah we all agree it it is it is in a
sense a gesture but it's an important
one and i i i could be wrong and if the
government has more information maybe
the the russian ambassador to canada
right now uh is is saying something to
our government or will say something
publicly against putin i've not heard
that i think we would very much welcome
that and that could change our position
but at this point we have not heard the
russian ambassador say anything against
what putin's doing which means he's he's
on side and in that case he needs to
leave the country and it's our
government
[Applause]
questions and comments kiss joey come
out there the honourable member for
edmonton griesbach
thank you very much mr speaker i want to
thank my honorable colleague
i myself represent an alberta district
and edmonton griezbaugh and there's many
ukrainian families who come to me
looking for support particularly for
their loved ones overseas right now this
government's ircc system is backlogged
it's broken and it's not effective would
the member please comment and elaborate
on the need to reunify uh ukrainian
families and the need to ensure that rcc
plays a major role in reuniting
ukrainians and bringing them to safety
thank you mr speaker the honourable
leader of the opposition thank you very
much and i appreciate that question i
think we're all feeling the same way
that we want to be able to to help
ukrainians who are fleeing as i said in
my speech i don't think ukrainian people
want to be permanent refugees anywhere
they want to be able to live in their
home nation of ukraine a free sovereign
peaceful nation but in the meantime
canada can be a safe haven uh our
suggestion is that we we asked the
government if they would uh remove the
the visa requirement
and i think the fact is we all saw what
happened when when afghanistan came
under attack and the fact that we were
not able to bring people to canada and
protect them in the way that was
expected of a nation like canada so what
we're trying to say to the government is
let's get rid of the red tape right now
so that we can immediately try to help
people who want to come to canada and be
protected until peace is restored in
their home needs
questions and comments
the honourable member for saanich gulf
islands thank you mr speaker
uh
to the honorable member who of course
and the leader of the conservative party
would she and her party consider asking
adding to the list of actions we should
take looking across canada at the assets
in this country bought by russian
oligarchs millions of dollars in real
estate can we move fast and seize those
assets to send a message to putin and
his cronies
the honorable leader of the opposition i
think
uh mr speaker i thank my honorable
colleague for that question i think
that's definitely something that we very
much could support uh i think that it's
very disturbing to see putin's assets
being protected hidden uh and uh and the
money laundering you know i think money
laundering has been is a big problem in
canada not just uh with russian uh
oligarchs but also
with chinese so this is something this
is a prime opportunity to deal with some
of these major problems that we have
seen
occurring in in the country and canada
should not be a safe haven for the for
gangsters thugs dictators to protect
their money that has to stop this is a
the best time we're all in agreement
let's get it done and uh and let's
punish some of these dictionaries
[Music]
questions and comments questions
the honourable member for central
okanagan some coming at nicola thank you
mr speaker i'd like to thank my leader
for her speech today canada is united
for the people of ukraine one of the
things that she did raise in her speech
was the importance of
europe's uh reliance on russian
gas and how that's put so much at risk
it's funding the very missiles the very
uh tanks that are invading into ukraine
today
canada can play that special role we
also know the americans they bring in
590 000 barrels of russian oil every day
can canada not just assure the european
security through our
our our energy products but can we also
work with the americans to secure north
american uh markets so that we keep
we keep putin away
from uh from being financed from our
dollars from the americans dollars for
the europeans uh dollars mr speaker
the honorable leader of the opposition
thank you mr speaker and i think what
we're seeing highlighted uh there is
some areas that have been ignored or
maybe not represented in an honest
real way over the last number of years
today and the last week have really come
to light and one of them is the issue of
canadian oil and gas and the benefit
that it plays on the world stage we've
been long proponents saying canada is
the most ethically responsible oil and
gas but usually it's in the conversation
around the environment and climate
change so we've been fighting for
canadian oil and gas to be used on the
world stage because we believe it's
actually the best thing for the
environment but lo and behold mr speaker
it's actually the best thing for the
world's safety security and energy
sovereignty we are seeing that today so
we're here to say as conservatives and
we think it's time that the whole house
would agree let's be champions of
canadian oil and gas
because it's good for the environment
but even more importantly it's good to
protect our sovereignty and we're seeing
today the the biggest threat
to our globe right now mr speaker
are dictators and tyrants like vladimir
putin
so let's put that into perspective and
let's do what we can as canadians to
protect sovereignty peace and security
and we do that by getting canadian
energy to the world
[Applause]
family
yes
is
i must
a
[Music]
with an iron
[Music]
is
[Music]
my
ukrainian
i say this with all due respect but when
it comes to that
i take issue
is
is
oh
ukraine
[Applause]
[Music]
um
um
there
[Music]
necessary now to offer these men and
women military personnel civilians
to preserve and protect their duty
[Music]
foreign
uh
of using only natural gas that comes
from canada rather than buying natural
gas and oil from other countries
the honorable member for belgium
in
is
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much mr speaker i want to
thank my honorable colleague for his
wonderful speech many things we agree
with as a matter of fact one part i'd
like the member to elaborate more on mr
speaker is that
in regards to funding for our allies in
ukraine and making sure that they have
the resources they need the government
hasn't matter of fact
been able to support ukraine with some
funding but much more needs to be done
would the member agree that money in
hand for the government of ukraine is
needed now more than ever thank you very
much mr speaker
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and i appreciate courage
a disaster
[Music]
is
human induced climate change and the war
on ukraine
have the same roots
fossil fuels and our dependence on them
we will not surrender in ukraine and we
hope the world will not surrender and
build in building a climate resilient
future
[Applause]
[Music]
and uh
are they ready to really truly face
climate change
exports will help ukraine
is
is
[Music]
a dictator
from what we understand ukrainians are
waging a very courageous battle
to maintain its dignity
then i think yes indeed there should be
the same sanctions imposed
[Applause]
is
may i ask you for your patience and
please persevere and you
thank you very much mr speaker
you can do
new democrats strongly condemn
president putin's flagrant aggression
against ukraine
and we stand in solidarity with the
people of ukraine
my thoughts go out to all ukrainians who
are worried about this unprovoked and
unjustified attack by russia
war always brings terrible loss of life
and human suffering
and as canada has welcomed a significant
population of ukrainian canadians
i spoke with some of them today who
shared their worries their fears
spoke with a young man whose parents
still live in ukraine
and despite the fact that his parents
live
in the western region which hasn't seen
as much military action
his family lives just kilometers away
from where rockets fell
i spoke with bodonna
and she shared with me her fears that
she can't sleep at night she has family
and friends she's got cousins that she's
trying to sponsor
and she can't sleep at night without
making sure that they're okay
she hasn't slept many hours over the
past number of days she's constantly
checking in constantly worried that
something might happen
these are just two of the many many
stories of ukrainian canadians who are
deeply worried about what's happening in
ukraine
and in this serious crisis
i want to outline two specific things
there's two specific areas where canada
can play a
significant role
in supporting people in this time
one is with stronger and more severe
sanctions and secondly is with an
emphasis on humanitarian relief i'll
begin with the sanctions
the liberal government must use must
continue to use
all tools to deter
putin's aggressive actions
and what we can specifically do is to
impose additional
economic sanctions
where it hurts
where it hurts putin
and that's by sanctioning putin's
closest oligarchs
i spoke with bill browder
who
is the author and the motivating force
behind the benitsky laws in canada and
the meniscus and big nancy act in other
countries
he has outlined that the current
sanctions
that are in place both
in canada and in other countries ignore
many of the ultra wealthy oligarchs who
hoard putin's wealth
these oligarchs are well known through
the diligent work of many activists and
advocates including mr browder
we can use the meniscus laws in canada
there's two categories both one for
human rights violations and secondly for
corruption
we know who these oligarchs are
many of them were identified by alexey
navalny
who was a political opponent we all know
that putin imprisoned tortured and
attempted to kill with poison
we need to
use the tools that we have to
hit putin where it hurts
the money that he's hoarded in the names
of the oligarchs whose money is
whose money is in country or the money
the resources are located in countries
around the world
we also need more tools to identify
where oligarchs are hiding their money
and to deal with money laundering in
general
we can accelerate the creation of a
publicly available nationwide beneficial
ownership registry this would provide
transparency on property ownership in
canada including those owned by
oligarchs who we know have property in
canada and the current timeline for this
registry is 2025 which is simply too far
away
putin's greed is well documented it is
his weakness it is well known that the
oligarchs hoard his wealth the wealth
that he has stolen from the russian
people
we need to stand up to putin and do it
in a way where it hurts him most and
that is his wealth and that is by
sanctioning those oligarchs the tools
that we have we need to do that that
would have a significant leverage in
putting pressure on putin to end this
war
secondly we need more support in
humanitarian aid and i break that down
into two areas since russia invaded
crimea in 2014 1.5 million ukrainians
have been displaced from their homes
many came to canada after the initial
invasion eight years ago and have
successfully resettled in communities
across the country with russia's current
invasion of ukraine the situation for
people on the ground has become
unfathomably more dire
ukrainians will be seeking safety and
refuge in canada and for years we've
been calling for
visa-free access for ukrainians and
calling for urgent action that's what we
need to do the government
must work collaboratively to support and
resettle those who've been displaced by
this escalating humanitarian crisis
we need to automatically expand extend
expiring documents and permits for all
ukrainians currently in canada
those who are already here should not be
compelled to return to
severe risks and danger in ukraine
we need to make sure it's easy and that
there is a barrier-free access for
people who are seeking refuge and safety
we also need to increase humanitarian
aid
ukrainian people need our support more
than ever and canada needs to plan for
that humanitarian aid
the crisis is worsening families are
torn apart
children have been killed
over half a million ukrainians have fled
the country in a few days with many more
internally displaced
all children in ukraine at least 7.5
million those that are under 18 years
old are in grave danger of physical harm
severe emotional distress and
displacement
canada must work with our allies
including the united nations to respond
appropriately
to this terrible situation
as we've seen with the syrian crisis
neighboring countries who host refugees
rely on significant support from those
donor communities to ensure that the
basic needs of the refugees and local
populations are met so we ask the
government to ensure that additional
funds to ukraine will not be diverted
from the existing humanitarian envelope
that continue to necessitate canada's
attention
we are pleased to see the matching funds
for the 10 million dollars with the red
cross but this is just a drop in the
bucket in terms of the massive needs
we need a plan with significant
financial commitments to helping
ukrainians both within ukraine and those
who have managed to get to safety in
neighboring countries
members of canada's humanitarian
coalition are operating in ukraine and
its neighboring countries they also
deserve our support canadian
community the ukrainian community in
canada is also offering to provide
support and is raising funds we need to
support those efforts as well we know
that there will soon be a u.n call for
funding and canada must provide its fair
share of support for this call
democrats
ukraine
ukrainian
ukrainians
refugees here in canada so that they can
in light of the escalating crisis
we must recognize that ukrainians
seeking safety from the dangers
right now in their homeland do not have
months to spare
the most urgent action is required the
government must do everything in its
power to help these people find safe
haven from the threat of violence in
ukraine caused by russia
do democrats stand in solidarity with
ukraine
with the people of ukraine
we commend and acknowledge their courage
and we will offer and we encourage this
government to offer all how possible to
support them in this time of need thank
you
questions and comments just like them
all paul the honourable member for
scarborough guildwood thank you uh mr
speaker i commend the honorable member
for his uh his thoughts in his speech
and
i am
it seems to be a general consensus that
sanctions are the way to go specifically
magnitsky sanctions
when he mentioned that it had a
conversation with bill browder i've i've
always
appreciated the advice that mr browder
has shared with me over the years and i
was just wondering whether uh he could
share with the house
any specific thoughts that mr browder
had with respect to
sanctions and and any specificity
on particularly on magnitsky sanctions
member for burnaby south
thank you very much for the question uh
mr browder really wanted to highlight
that the sanctions will only work if
they target putin and what we've seen is
putin is not someone who cares about his
country he has robbed from the country
but he does care about his wealth and
his wealth is hoarded by oligarchs and
he pointed out that the magnitsky laws
provide for a provision of
corruption and where we can identify
corruption there's many cases where we
can tie oligarchs that are close to
putin with corruption and that those
oligarchs need to be sanctioned so we
need to start naming and sanctioning
specific oligarchs closely connected to
putin involved in corruption and
that is something that will
significantly impact routine in a way
that can apply real leverage and
pressure on him to stop this war
questions and comments questions
the honourable member for selkirk
interlake eastman well thank you mr
speaker and i want to thank the leader
of the ndp for his comments and i know
that um you know he was talking about
maninski sanctions as a matter of fact
like it was i've worked very closely
with bill browder when senator ray
nalandrik formerly in the the other
place and i brought forward legislation
here in 2017 to
have the meninski act become legislation
unfortunately the federal government
hasn't used meninski sanctions since
2018
and really for people to understand how
the kleptocracy works in the kremlin and
in russia and understand how corrupt
vladimir putin and his inner circle is
that everyone needs to read red notice
the book bill brother bill browder wrote
about sergey minski who is his lawyer an
accountant who was trying to tell the
truth of what was happening there and of
course he was sadly
arrested
impuned beaten and then died of his
injuries in prison
so we know that we
have a lot more work to do so i'd ask
the leader of the ndp if you want to
talk more about how the government
should be using minsky sanctions since
it sends the message in concert with our
allies around the world that our country
cannot be used as a safe haven for those
who are corrupt foreign officials for
those that are wrenching themselves
through uh
you know
stealing from their own citizenry and
for those are uh
really having uh and causing gross human
rights violations and we have never seen
human rights violations a long time at
the level that we're witnessing right
now in ukraine all carried out by
vladimir putin and his war machine
honourable member for burnaby south
uh thank you mr speaker and thank you
for the question
what uh what's been identified really
clearly is if we want to apply pressure
on putin
the current approach of sanctions while
important symbolically will not impact
putin
he is someone who is amassed significant
wealth
by stealing from his own country
so sanctions on the country will not be
sufficient
to curtail his actions or to send a
clear message that will actually hurt
putin personally that is the only way to
apply pressure in this case is to make
the pain be felt by mr put by president
putin and to do that
we know that his wealth is held and
hoarded by oligarchs they need to be and
many of them have been identified by
many different advocates we need to
identify and sanction those specific
oligarchs with the meninski law with the
sanctions we have the powers that we
have and that will send a very powerful
message and hurt putin where it counts
his greed and his wealth amassed by by
stealing from the country from stealing
from russians that is what we need to do
and that is a powerful tool that is yet
has yet to be used effectively and
that's a part of what we're calling for
to apply real leverage and pressure to
end what is going on in ukraine to end
the violence
and to stop
putin from continuing to do it
questions
foreign
is
[Applause]
is
um
the oligarchy
and there we can hit putin where it
hurts
questions
questions and comments the honourable
member for elmwood transcona
much mr speaker and thank you to the
leader of the ndp for his strong
condemnation of the
attack by russia on the ukraine for his
support for measures that will take the
fight directly to vladimir putin and his
suggestion
to take up some of the measures that
myself and other new democrat colleagues
have suggested for a long time to help
ukrainians get to canada in an expedited
fashion by for example eliminating the
visa requirement of course we know
one component of
putin's attack on the ukraine
has to do very much with disinformation
and how and how
uh putin and and the russian
administration under him has excelled at
propagating disinformation through
social media we've felt effects of that
even here in canada we've known for a
long time part of the russian strategy
has been to de-center western
democracies through disinformation and
we're going to have to be very vigilant
during the the the battle between
ukrainian forces and russian forces
to
understand and appreciate the role of
disinformation i'm wondering if he has
some thoughts on what government can do
and individual canadians can do
to fight against the propagation of
disinformation and social media
global member for burnaby south
thank my honorable colleague for the
question and it's very true we've seen
already the impacts of this campaign of
disinformation led by russia to
particularly target democracies and they
do so by propagating messages
information and propaganda that is
incorrect
to
repeat
the lines that russia is encouraging
people to believe and information that
is designed to subvert democracies and
to
incite hatred against different groups
in this case against ukraine we've seen
clear concerted attempts to incite
hatred against ukraine that are baseless
and propaganda that's baseless and so a
couple of things that we can do first of
all be very careful when we see
information be very careful about the
source
make sure it's a source that you trust a
source that's been that's been verified
before spreading any of those messages
there's a clear effort and we will be
targeted with different disinformation
secondly government has a strong role to
play we've seen through a number of
different accounts including
whistleblowers that social media
benefits from divisive rhetoric and
comments and they
they amplify messages that might divide
people because it'll keep whether people
criticizing that message or supporting
it'll keep more people on their platform
so governments have to play a role in
ensuring that disinformation is not
spread it's not allowed to be spread and
it can't be left in the hands of social
media companies which will
give those messages that are divisive
that create controversy more space and
amplify them in people's feeds so that
is why government has to take a role in
stopping the spread of that information
and something we've long called for
resuming debate represent the honourable
member for etobicoke center
thank you very much mr speaker and i'll
be sharing my time with the member for
thunder bay rainy river
i'm proud to rise today to speak during
this emergency taking debate in the
house of commons
on ukraine and russia's military
invasion
a couple of days ago i was joined by
several of my colleagues in requesting
this emergency take note debate in the
house of commons we felt it was
important as it provided an opportunity
for members of all parties all parts of
the country
to speak to this issue to discuss
candidates in the international
community's response to what's happening
in ukraine
and i'd like to thank all parties for
the support of that motion to have this
emergency take note debate
during our last take no debate i shared
a story with all of you about my
grandfather yvonne that i was with him
when ukraine declared its independence
that he was a great patriot that when
ukraine declared its independence it
might have been the proudest day of his
life
that my grandfather
said to me that day
that now that ukraine is independent we
have to keep up the fight for ukraine's
independence i was 14 years old at the
time and i said what are you talking
about
ukraine's declared its independence the
people want it the world has recognized
it i said you are wrong
and i was wrong
in 2014 russia twice invaded ukraine in
crimea and eastern ukraine in 2014
the world did not do enough
they didn't impose enough sanctions they
didn't send weapons
they didn't do enough to support ukraine
and to deter an invasion
now vladimir putin has begun an
unprovoked full-scale invasion of
ukraine he has attacked the entire
country and not just the soldiers
defending ukraine's borders but he's
targeting and killing
civilians
men women children he's bombing
buildings
and he's bombing kindergarten
and much more
[Applause]
civilians are dying as we speak
the courage of the ukrainian people and
the ukrainian armed forces
have been inspired
and it's not just soldiers who are
fighting courageously
it's men women people of all ages
seniors are taking up arms they are
outnumbered and they are outgunned but
they keep fighting
and they're holding the line against a
much larger much more
well-armed military
in ukrainian we say slava ukraine
this means glory to the glory to ukraine
and glory to the heroes
i think we can all agree that ukrainians
are living up to those words right now
for those of us with
those of us with ukrainian ancestry this
touches us personally but this is
something that concerns all canadians
it's a humanitarian crisis
we see not just the soldiers being
killed but civilian civilians being
killed civilians displaced civilian
communities being bombed there's an
attack on ukraine's sovereignty but it's
also an attack on democracy and in the
international rules based order it's a
threat not just ukraine security but the
europe security the world security and
canada security
ukrainians are fighting bravely
and yes they're fighting for their
freedom
they're fighting for their homeland
but they're also fighting for something
else
they're fighting for all of us
today
this impacts all of us this affects all
our security affects democracy around
the world it affects global security
today they are fighting for all of us
today
we are all
the
ukrainian
are fighting for us
the koreans are fighting for us and we
need to fight for them
and that is why canada and its allies
must do everything possible
to stop this invasion and to ensure
russia withdraws from ukraine
now canada has taken a tremendous number
of steps along with our allies
we've today we banned crude oil exports
we provided we announced
the announcement we announced that we're
going to provide additional lethal
weapons to ukraine anti-tackle tank
weapons and other rockets and other
systems that ukraine's have requested
we've asked we will ask we've announced
that we will ask crtc to review
rt's presence on our airwaves we need to
get rid of rt in canada we've previously
provided two shipments of weapons we've
traded over 30 000 ukrainian soldiers
who are fighting so bravely as we speak
right now and we've imposed tremendous
number of sanctions against vladimir
putin his oligarchs
and on the central bank and much more
and these sanctions are having a
significant impact
but it won't be enough
it won't be enough until vladimir putin
is stopped until ukraine is free
today this house unanimously supported
by motion which called
upon canada to do a number of things
including continuing to impose sanctions
the provision of additional support to
the government of ukraine and the
ukrainian armed forces
issuing an additional order uh an order
around to the crtc around rt and and
broadcasting policy and the removal of
russia from swift from the payment
system
we have to keep working until we stop
vladimir putin
until the ukrainians win
they are fighting for us in 1991 that
day with my grandfather
i was wrong in 2014 the world was wrong
there is too much at stake ukraine
security is europe's security and it's
canada security ukrainians are fighting
bravely for freedom but they're also
fighting for us and we need to fight for
them today we are all ukrainian today
everyone in the free world is ukrainian
and today we can all say
glory to ukraine
glory to the heroes
[Applause]
questions and comments the honourable
member for regina was genna
thank you mr speaker
saskatchewan has a large ukrainian
community with as many as 15 percent of
the province's population tracing their
roots back to ukraine
last week the provincial government of
saskatchewan sent a letter to this
government
asking them to prioritize immigration
applicants from ukraine who have already
applied under the saskatchewan immigrant
nominee program as well as to fast-track
refugee applications from ukrainians
bound for saskatchewan
mr speaker can the government commit to
working closely with the provincial
government of saskatchewan on these
priority items so that we can help as
many ukrainians as possible
the honourable member for etobicoke
center
i think i thank the member for his
question and for
for his advocacy
around helping those ukrainians who are
displaced who are fleeing their country
and who need our help
i think canada has an important role to
play in making sure that we support
those who need our help and providing
that humanitarian assistance and also
welcoming ukrainians to canada
where they can find refuge and i think
the government of canada has been
working very closely with provincial
governments uh and will continue to i'm
sure but i think what the government of
canada has shown to date through the
measures that have been announced over
the last few days and today is that
we're taking every step possible to
ensure that we allow we help facilitate
ukrainians coming to canada and finding
safety here and continuing to build this
great country as ukrainian canadians
have for generations thank you speaker
questions
thank you very much mr speaker and i'd
like to thank my colleague for his
speech
it's been raised a few times
for people who want to come to canada
urgently whether it be temporary or
permanent i'd like to hear my colleague
on that please thank you
honorable member for
etobicoke center
thank you mr speaker
does
to ensure that ukrainians can get to
canada safe safely
questions and comments the honourable
member for victoria
thank you mr speaker and i want to thank
the member for his speech and for his
words in solidarity with the people of
ukraine whether they are bringing their
children to safety or fighting for
freedom and democracy ukrainians are
showing the world what courage looks
like
and we have to support them i've spoken
to so many people in my community here
in victoria who are worried about their
family members they have parents
grandparents people with disabilities
people with young children they're
trying to get to safety and they need to
get here quickly
we know that our immigration and refugee
system is broken it's extremely
backlogged we're witnessing this
unfolding humanitarian crisis can the
members speak to the urgent need to put
more resources and measures to support
those
in need of support and resettlement uh
fleeing putin's violence and does he
agree that canada should provide
visa-free access to all ukrainians
the honourable member for etobicoke
center
well i thank the member for her for her
words for her intervention for advocacy
uh and for her question
um
look i believe the humanitarian needs
are
tremendous um
i actually asked a question of the
minister about this today civilians are
being killed as we speak
hundreds of thousands now millions
frankly are being displaced and fleeing
and there's a tremendous need for the
world uh to do so much more to support
those who are fleeing and uh and i
certainly believe that to be the case um
and as far as as as allowing ukrainians
to come visa-free i think
those who look at my record will know
that i've had
about my advocacy to ensure that we
facilitate closer people to people ties
with ukraine over the years and i will
continue to do that and there's no time
more important than now when ukrainians
are in need and and canada can help and
we and the government has done that
we'll continue to do that
resuming debate replies
the honourable member for thunder bay
rainey river
thank you mr speaker many canadians have
a connection with ukraine first and
foremost there's a lot of new immigrants
from the ukraine in canada
and first and foremost my thoughts are
with them who have immediate family and
friends in ukraine i can certainly
imagine what it's like for them every
time they hear the phone ring wondering
who's calling and about what
but there are many many other canadians
like myself i spent the first number of
years of my life
living with my parents and grandparents
in a part of fort william which is now
thunder bay which has a large ukrainian
canadian population my baba was from
near horodenko my guido grandfather was
from new york kamenetz pedolsky
i spent many summer evenings as a child
sitting with my baba on the on the steps
of her corner store which actually
wasn't on the corner um and and partly
because baba used to brazenly bribe me
with fudgicals and and and creamsicles
from the store in order to get me to sit
with her but she would sit for hours
singing old ukrainian hymns and and
telling stories about what used to
happen in the old country that was in
between coming and going from the store
and selling people cigarettes and candy
now because so many of my early memories
revolve around
the ukraine and and and ukrainians
even though i don't speak ukrainian even
though i've only visited ukraine once in
my life i feel very much
that
ukraine is part of my soul
now of course you don't have to be
ukrainian in order to sympathize with
what's happening in the ukraine or with
ukrainians
we all see the pictures but
the pictures are only a very small part
of what's happening in the ukraine now
certainly we have statistics contested
statistics about number of deaths number
of
injuries but let's remember what
what
joseph stalin once said which is a
million deaths is a tragedy
or a million deaths is a statistic one
death is a tragedy and certainly
for each statistic every death is a
tragedy it means a phone call to a
parent telling them that a child will
not be coming home or a child who won't
have their parent coming home as they
told them they would
all of this tragedy is the direct and
total responsibility of vladimir putin
and the people who support vladimir
putin
it is vladimir putin who decided to walk
in the steps of joseph stalin
ukrainians and russians are in fact
brothers and sisters
but this is brother killing brother the
only brother that kills his brother is a
madman like putin
but let's not forget in this immense
human tragedy worthy of dostoyevsky
the suffering of many russians as well
many of whom were dying fighting their
brothers and sisters in the ukraine let
us not also forget about the mothers and
fathers of russian soldiers who were
anxiously awaiting their return from the
ukraine
now as a doctor who certainly dealt with
death and has worked in places where i
saw a lot of trauma including close to
war zones i can absolutely tell you that
the suffering of a parent losing a child
or the suffering of a child losing a
parent is exactly the same it doesn't
matter whether you're from ethiopia or
haiti from thunder bay ottawa or from
ukraine or russia
now mr speaker am i a lot of time i
could have talked about more lofty
issues the fact that how this invasion
presents an existential threat to the
international legal order which it
certainly does and how that
international legal order grew in no
small part under the second world war
and
um the fact that in so many ways the u.n
charter and international legal order
was the result of the second world war
and the sacrifices so many russians and
ukrainians made in that war
i also don't have time too much to talk
about what we can and can do other than
to repeat what a number of people in our
party have said which is that all
options remain on the table to my family
in the ukraine some of whom i know as i
speak are waiting with guns for the
russians to come for their parents who
were worried and praying for them for
the people of the ukraine for the very
many good russian people let me tell you
i support you my family supports you the
canadian people support you indeed good
people all around the world support you
and certainly
this parliament supports you slav
comments questions
the honorable member for beth airdrove
mr speaker now one of the most effective
tools that the world has at its disposal
right now is to stop uh the you know the
imports of russian uh oil and gas uh and
you know i i certainly will say that i
do acknowledge and congratulate the
government for stopping uh that from
coming into canada but uh we also could
with our canadian energy be
the the replacement for that russian oil
and natural gas with our good clean
environmentally responsible uh
and friendly canadian oil and gas and so
uh i would i would just say that had the
liberal government only recognized that
that those benefits of our energy that
environmentally friendly energy that it
is the ability to grow our economy and
create jobs here in canada and for the
way that our energy respects human
rights and would
would enable peace and security in the
world by stopping dictators from put
like vladimir putin from being the
source of energy instead um you know we
would have a much safer place we would
have much stronger ability to to go
after the russians for what they're
doing uh in ukraine so will that liberal
government finally get behind
our oil and gas and stop preventing its
success
the honourable member for thunder bay
rainey river the member opposite for his
question and indeed hindsight is 20 20.
and i i think most of us a month ago two
months ago six months ago wouldn't have
predicted that putin would actually have
gone into ukraine as to the situation
right now and whether we should cut off
russian supplies of oil and gas to
canada i i personally support it however
the devil is always into detail like
what what is the alternative right now
we certainly don't want people unable to
heat their houses businesses closing
down in quebec because they don't have
access to heat or well but i think our
government has already said and made
clear that all options are on the table
i think this is certainly something we
we have to consider and certainly i
think we need to go on an economic
blitzkrieg against russia we have to go
on multiple fronts against russia like
russia went against ukraine however we
can harm russia economically we ought to
do whether it means imports exports
financial connections absolutely
everything we go after russia
questions
foreign
the member for thunder bay rainey river
i i thank you for the member for the
block for for
her remarks and
to tell you the truth i personally
hadn't considered um what we're going to
do with belarus when
i was a question period today and in
fact i admit when the bloc brought up
belarus it kind of caught me off guard
but absolutely i agree with you that i
personally i can't speak for the
government but but i agree with you that
that
countries have to choose size it's the
same with china like choose a side
you're either on the side of
globalization in the right side or
you're on the wrong side belarus chose
they chose to be on russia's side let
them suffer the same consequences of
russia
questions and comments questions
the honourable member for
malahat langford
couch in malachi langhorne thank you so
much mr speaker um i appreciate my
colleague speech and i thank him for for
his passion um there is evidence that
russian forces have intentionally
attacked civilians and civilian targets
and so mr speaker i want to know his
thoughts about how canada can contribute
to gathering evidence of possible war
crimes and how we can hold the russian
military leadership to account and make
sure they come to justice for the
commission of any uh war crimes and
secondly mr speaker i was incredibly
moved by the thousands of russian
citizens in saint petersburg and moscow
who risked brutal imprisonment to
protest for peace and i'm just wondering
if he can comment on that because we
need to isolate putin but not go after
the russian people many of whom want
peace and didn't want this war in the
first place
the honourable member for thunder bay
rainey river in 30 seconds or less
please i'd like to thank the member for
his observations and absolutely the
russian people are not our enemy the
enemy is putin there's very many good
russian people there's very many people
in russia who are suffering seeing their
kids going off to fight a war that that
they themselves do not want and and
certainly
they're on our side they're they're not
on putin's side um as for war crimes and
things i i would say i would i would
take a step back further in and even
suggest this which is that what really
kind of goals me is the fact that russia
continues to sit on the security council
and be the president of proceedings
dealings with what's happening in
ukraine i mean
and
they for them to be the decision-making
body in the u.n i think we have to
fundamentally start looking at some of
the underpinnings of the un including
russia who clearly is not in favor of
globalization the world order in their
position in the international legal
order
resuming debate represent the honorable
member for durham
thank you very much mr speaker it's
always a pleasure to rise in this house
representing my home communities in
durham
and last time arose in this house on
january 31st my speech was on ukraine mr
speaker
and of course
a lot has changed since that speech mr
speaker of course for me and where i sit
in this chamber
but more importantly in something that
has had the world transfixed
our fears about a russian invasion
were actualized
we've seen horrific
videos of indiscriminate violence
towards civilian populations by mr putin
and his russian aggression we've seen
inspiring stories of parliamentarians of
elderly people of people who've never
held a rifle
picking one up to defend their land to
defend their community to defend their
country
so our fears
have been actualized mr speaker and when
i last rose in this house
i never thought we would see the extent
of aggression we see
so being back and it's good to be back
mr speaker
i want to start off by thanking all
members of this house for their remarks
tonight this has been nice to see
all sides coming together to stand up
for our friends in ukraine
[Applause]
i want to thank the government for
moving on weapons for our allies in
ukraine that was the subject of our
debate
a month ago mr speaker i want to thank
them for the aid that's been provided
the move alongside our allies to take
russia out of the swift financial system
the restrictions on airspace there must
be a full court press
of both diplomatic and security
pressures brought to bear to halt this
aggression and save lives mr speaker and
i want to thank the government i want to
thank the conservative opposition and
all members of this house for this
debate tonight
i'd also like to thank canadians
business leaders community and charity
leaders across the country stepping up
donating doing drives to raise awareness
and raise funds to help
and particularly i want to thank the
ukrainian canadian community mr speaker
who have always inspired me
from my very first speech as a fledgling
politician in the nepro hall in oshawa
with members of the long-standing
ukrainian community there the ukrainian
the league of ukrainian canadians the
ukrainian canadian congress
charities credit unions across this
country are stepping up and i know that
is providing hope
so the debate we have here tonight mr
speaker is one of unity because
it's about the values we represent as a
country
the commitment to liberty to democracy
to the rule of law that we want to see
our millions of friends in ukraine have
as well mr speaker
and it's been shocking to hear some of
the stories
this morning i heard an interview with a
ukrainian member of parliament she's 37
ina soofsan
and here's what she said speaking to a
canadian journalist mr speaker
i'm so much better with words than with
arms
but i will pick up arms
if it comes to that end quote
we're so fortunate in this house mr
speaker that we never have to worry
about going beyond our words
the very fact that we see the president
we see members of all sides of their
parliament
stepping up inspiring and even taking up
arms to defend
their land
it's something as canadians we have to
act
and we have to be relevant
within nato within the united nations
within the g7 the g20 to make sure
countries like ukraine don't face
this brazen
aggression this hostility of the highest
order
or else we will become a world where
politicians have to stop the words and
pick up the arms mr speaker
and that's a scary notion
so i want miss suv's son to know
parliamentarians around the world
including here in canada are going to
fight hard to make sure she can continue
to fight with her words
and her democracy
and not have to resort to picking up
arms
so in the spirit of cooperation with my
words of thanks
i would like to provide
two recommendations to the government in
this debate
[Music]
so there's two very specific
recommendations that i'd like to bring
to the government's attention
first is we have to have a return to
interest-based foreign policy
what are our interests from an economic
and trade standpoint what are our
diplomatic our humanitarian assistance
interests as a nation what are our
security concerns
our defense alliances
as a country we are one of the most
multilateral countries in the world
because we've always
had to be as a trading nation
as a nation that straddles the northern
half
of the americas mr speaker a nation
born not of revolution but evolution
from an empire and now stand as one of
the world's great democracies
we have to have our foreign policy
not based
on appealing
to
small groups
appealing to the the issue of the day
we have to make it based on our
strategic long-term interests as a
country and
on our values as a country mr speaker
the deputy prime minister when she laid
out this government's foreign policy
approach in a speech in this place in
2017
she began her remarks with a question
is canada an essential country
at this time in the life of our planet
and quote mr speaker
it then did not really lay out interests
but laid out a number of emerging issues
and we've seen that repeatedly with
progressive trade agendas with climate
change and other issues
outflanking
our economic our security our trade our
diplomatic our humanitarian
interest as a country
and that has to change mr speaker
because
all issues are a priority from climate
change
to some of the progressive trade agenda
that was promoted with the united states
but our security as a country our
relevance within nato within norad
are critical to what our country must
advance and so i would ask the
government in the spirit of cooperation
we see her to make sure that we have
the equipment we need for our canadian
armed forces that we arm our diplomats
our aid workers with the tools and the
funds they need
to
assert our interest and will around the
world mr speaker
we've been lulled out of a sense of
complacency
the second recommendation i would have
mr speaker relates to our arctic
something that i've been talking about
for many years something that i was
pleased to work with michael levitt when
he was chair of the foreign affairs
committee and we conducted the most
robust examination of our interests in
the arctic
in a generation
nation building at home vigilance beyond
preparing for the coming decades in the
arctic
an april 2019 report
it stated that the arctic is fundamental
and an indivisible part of canada and
that right now
when we wrote it in 2019 our sovereignty
is at risk
the first section of that report mr
speaker
dealt
with russian military and security
buildup in their portion of the arctic
russian
interest in the continental shelf
russian interests in polar
trade and
circumnavigation routes mr speaker
we are decades behind where we need to
be in asserting our arctic sovereignty
we the north mr speaker should be more
than a hashtag that we use when we're
proud of our basketball team
this defining element of our country
right now is in jeopardy so we need the
ships the drones the personnel the
rangers the infrastructure investments
to realize the true potential of canada
and recognize
that we are a neighboring country to
russia mr speaker
we also have to based on our national
interest
and a foreign policy based on that help
our friends in ukraine
so the continued support
through
the
winding down of the swift financial
system
in
sanctions including the magninsky
sanctions help brought in by my friend
from selkirk interlake eastman we need
to make sure that we have
the military equipment needed for
ukraine to defend itself and we should
work within nato to see how we can put
parameters
including looking at restricting the
ability for russia to inflict more
damage
and then of course help with refugee
support mr speaker
the 1.4 million ukrainian canadians
have helped build this country
canada was the first nation
to recognize ukraine
and tonight
let's show as parliamentarians that we
will continue to be one of the strongest
one of the most consistent and one of
the most steadfast allies of ukraine
thank you mr speaker
questions and comments questions
the honourable member for king's hands
to thank my honorable colleague for his
remarks uh and his speech here tonight
and it's great to see him back in the
host uh some of what the uh what my
honorable colleague touched upon are
actually things that are going to be in
what i have the chance to say uh later
today but this gentleman
my colleague has served in our canadian
armed forces he has
defended and protected our country and i
thank him for that my question is of
course
actually around the military presence
the united states indeed we have ruled
out the idea of having canadian troops
in ukraine of course the minister of
defense has said that we will
mobilize 3 500 troops to support our
nato commitments this member served in
that capacity could he give his thoughts
to us as our colleagues in this house
about what point canada has to mobilize
beyond its initial sixty thousand are we
at that point in terms of our complement
of canadian armed forces or do we have
to be encouraging other canadians that
perhaps may take on the same profession
that he did before he joined this house
thank you
the honourable member for durham thank
you mr speaker i'd like to thank the
member from king's hands for his
thoughtful inquiry and i know
like i do he has a pride for the men and
women who serve in the canadian armed
forces particularly at cfb greenwood i
was stationed at shearwater and did a
lot of training at that incredible air
base and i think all parliamentarians
are proud of any canadian that steps up
to put a uniform of service on for their
country whether service at home which
we've seen
particularly in british columbia in
recent months mr speaker but we've been
also steadfast going back to the
conservative government mr speaker with
operations like unifier reassurance
we've had
great
collaboration within nato and
particularly training operations in
ukraine and in the baltics to make sure
that we have a presence
but i really do think that there's been
a creeping barrage of aggression by
vladimir putin and we've been lulled
into a sense of complacency
as a western world
starting in 2014 with the revolution of
dignity mr speaker that led mr
putin to go into crimea into the dawn
bass we saw the malaysian air flight 17
shot down we saw cyber attacks in 2015
that took out part of the ukraine
energy grid mr speaker there has been a
steadfast and consistent approach of
aggression and we've hoped that the
post-war world order would not change
it has changed so in the spirit of
cooperation i know that member shares an
interest in our canadian armed forces we
need a non-partisan plan
to build out capacity for our canadian
armed forces and for exerting
our
control over our land mass in the arctic
which right now even our friends in the
u.s
have stepped away from
the relationship mr mulrooney and
president reagan negotiated with respect
to the northwest passage mr speaker we
must act now
to help our friends in ukraine but also
to make sure we defend our own
territorial sovereignty
questions and comments questions
the questions
uh
the diplomatic approach to have
something more structured
and
our interests foreign country security
economic interest security interest
deployments earn a porsche
[Music]
see
[Applause]
honourable member for edmonton griezbach
thank you very much mr speaker and i
want to thank you i'm a member from
durham
i have a serious question and i hope
that this house can unite around how
important it is to ensure that we have
visa-free requirements for ukrainians
seeking safety we've heard several times
today this question been posed and i
really hope that we can get some unity
on this tonight and i'd like to ask the
member from durham whether or not the
conservatives agree with the ndp's
proposal from at least 2018 to ensure
visa travel free requirements for
ukrainians are waived
well member for durham
thank you very much mr speaker and i
think this is the first time i've had
the uh
chance to respond to the new member from
edmonton griezbaugh and i want to
welcome him to the house and thank him
for the question
and remind him that conservatives have
been asking for this for many years in
fact if i could have my friend from
selkirk into like eastman whisper me how
many years uh
it's been four mr speaker
one thing i think we're very proud of in
this house is strong deep historic ties
between ukraine and canada
and the more we can facilitate those
ties through parental grandparent family
travel through business relationships
through the free trade agreement that
my friend the honourable member from
abbotsford helped negotiate mr speaker
these are the
indications of a mature and important
relationship for our country so i agree
with him i do think that is something we
need we also need to work with allies
across europe particularly in poland
we've seen 500 000 people
already flee
and i want to speak for a moment about
someone that works on the hill who just
moved here from ukraine a couple of
years ago a friend daria fasenko i spoke
to her a few days ago all her family
are in eastern ukraine and have had to
hide out in the country away from a war
being inflicted in their country
daria is in contact every day and like
so many ukrainian canadians they're
worried about their family and that's
why it's so nice to see the house come
together tonight so nice to see canada
assert itself alongside our allies and
whatever we can do
to help this time of crisis we need to
do
questions and comments
the honourable member for sandwich gulf
violence
mr speaker and this is an evening of
remarkable consensus on all sides of the
house of our support for ukraine so i
and and its people and its brave and
inspiring president so i hate to find
one small part of the honorable
member for durham's speech that i really
do want to take up and and and ask him
to rethink it the the notion which he
may not have meant to sound as strong as
it did which was this government had
spent too much time looking at things
like climate change and needs to focus
more on national security in the economy
but those are the same things the
climate crisis threatens national
security and the economy and is the
report that just came out today from the
ipcc will further inform him but i
wanted to put to him these words which i
think are hard to say too much attention
on climate change when they come from dr
svetlana krakowska
who was the head of the ipcc
delegation from ukraine
and today she said this quote
human-induced climate change and the war
on ukraine have the same roots
fossil fuels and our dependence on them
we will not surrender in ukraine and we
hope the world will not surrender in
building a climate resilient future
these are consistent and convergent
goals not competing thank you mr speaker
the honourable member for durham
thank you very much mr speaker and i
would cite the report i referenced in my
remarks and invite the honourable member
to consult the report that our committee
did in 2019 nation building at home
vigilance beyond preparing for the
coming decades in the arctic and climate
change is part
of preparing for the arctic in fact
at the request of the conservatives that
foreign affairs report mr speaker was
the first report of a parliamentary
committee
prepared in the indigenous languages of
the partners we went me met with on the
ground that was conservative request mr
speaker because that resilience that
vigilance we need to build in our arctic
is the rangers for security but it's
also the impact of climate change
particularly on traditional ways of life
the challenge i have with this
government is it will sometimes
substitute
these these notions
and ignore the hard and fast
state craft mechanisms that we should
have
the government completely ignored the
need for us to be full partners in norad
that includes ballistic missile defense
it means
asserting our sovereignty in the arctic
it means supplying ships for the
canadian armed forces
we have to look at the world as the way
it is mr speaker and that's what i hope
tonight's debate can do to make sure
canada helps our friends in ukraine but
make sure we're prepared at home thank
you mr speaker
[Applause]
resuming debate the honorable
parliamentary secretary to the minister
of public services and procurement
thank you very much mr speaker and i
will be sharing time with the member
from king's hands
my time is short so i wanted to make
some quick points
over the last week the world around us
has changed and we need to adapt we need
to change with it
last week people across the world were
treated to two horrifying events that
occurred at exactly the same time
first what we've been talking about
tonight
russian missiles dropping on innocent
civilians in the ukraine
an illegal act of aggression committed
by vladimir putin in his regime against
a sovereign independent neighbor
the second
happened on our very continent in new
york where the russian ambassador was
chairing a meeting of the u.n security
council
the meeting was to discuss a resolution
condemning russian aggression against
ukraine
and after denying that russia ever
intended to invade the ukraine the
ambassador was confronted during the
meeting with missiles dropping on
ukraine from russian territory the
russian ambassador was then allowed to
continue to share the meeting
to which his country was the nin party
and then when his country was the only
one to vote against the resolution he
was able to veto it
mr speaker my first point
is that the united nations badly needs
reform
whether the security council
the human rights council where
dictatorships that abuse human rights
judge democracies
we need to reform this organization
my second point mr speaker is we need to
hold vladimir putin and those around him
in his regime his military commanders
those who support this aggression to
account
that means we need to find a way to
ensure that we let vladimir putin know
that he will be brought before an
international tribunal
the problem mr speaker
is that that international tribunal
would be the international criminal
court
and russia has not acceded to the rome
statute
therefore
in my understanding it would require a
referral from the security council
where russia would hold a veto coming
back to my first point we need to reform
that organization
i think mr speaker
we all
have been so incredibly proud to watch
the resolve of the ukrainian people
my heart goes out to all those who are
suffering there
and also to the ukrainian canadian
community
i'm also part of a diaspora
and i think you need to
be part of a diaspora to fully
understand the pain when your ancestral
homeland is attacked no matter how many
generations prior they were there and so
my heart goes out to those canadians
my heart
also goes out to the ukrainians who are
standing up not only for their democracy
and their freedom
but for ours but for the worlds
mr speaker
canadians can be inspired and learn from
ukrainians
and my third point
is that nobody in the ukraine today
is asking who they voted for in the last
election
or whether they believe in vaccine
mandates
people are pulling together
against a real threat to their country
we can use this example as a stark
reminder that there are a lot of threats
to canada in the world and we need to
pull together
and stop being divisive
we as members of parliament can set the
example
that we can disagree with people
without disliking or hating them we all
believe
in a strong united canada we are all
there to defend our country and we need
to pull together
mr speaker for the last number of years
we have had warning signs of real
threats to the world order
a rise of authoritarian strongman
regimes russia's annexation of crimea
repression by china and hong kong and
its threats in the south china sea
the rise of donald trump and
isolationism rising in the most powerful
democracy in the world
the attack in ukraine is a culmination
of this
and we need to rise to the challenge
my next point mr speaker is in this
battle ukraine is our friend and ally
and putin is not
there are not two sides to this
we need to fully support ukraine we need
to do everything we can to make sure
that the economy of russia
is absolutely destroyed so that putin's
act of aggression ends and that he is
replaced i've been very proud of how
canada has led in this regard my last
point mr speaker before my time ends is
that we need to seriously look at
increasing defense spending i understand
that military spending is not popular
but we are now faced with a world order
that is changing we are faced with new
challenges posed by cyber security and
disinformation russia is a neighbor in
the arctic we need to seriously consider
are we prepared to confront this new
world thank you mr speaker
questions and comments questions come on
terry the honourable member for regina
wisconna
thank you mr speaker vladimir putin
needs to understand that his invasion of
ukraine is totally unacceptable and
russia needs to become a pariah on the
world stage just like north korea
mr speaker will the government expel the
russian ambassador to canada and at the
same time recall canada's ambassador to
russia
the honorable parliamentary secretary
mr speaker as the honourable mayor knows
i don't speak for the government on this
issue um however
in my view
that would depend on whether or not we
believe the canadian ambassador in
russia would clearly be
expelled if we expelled the russian
ambassador is able to find things out on
the ground
that we need to know
i have no personal objection to strongly
considering the expulsion of the
ambassador but i think there's other
things that we need to do that are far
more important such as making sure that
sanctions are opposed in the strongest
manner against russia and such as making
sure that there is so much pressure that
the russians try to overthrow putin and
finally i i agree i'm in agreement that
russia should not be part of
international organizations as long as
the putin regime is in place
yes
come on
questions
questions and comments
to mr
hello
[Music]
the russian government
um
[Music]
thank you mr speaker and i want to thank
the member for his speech
it's great to see mps across party lines
united in their support for ukraine and
also united in their condemnation of
putin that's not the case everywhere and
the member mentioned donald trump in his
speech and it's appalling to see the
former u.s president praising putin
putin's government has a track record of
using disinformation to target
democracies
so my question is about how
disinformation has been used by the by
putin and by his regime to destabilize
to undermine support for ukraine and to
justify this unjustifiable war can the
members speak to what the government
needs to do to combat disinformation
online on social media and in our
communities
secretary
mr speaker i want to thank my colleague
for that excellent question uh we need
to make sure that the platforms are held
accountable for driving traffic to
disinformation
we have seen over and over that
platforms seek to monetize revenue and
make sure that people stay on their
platforms for as long as possible and
hate is driven to hate and people who
believe in one world theory are driven
to other conspiracy theories that they
would agree with to keep them on the
platform longer
we need to make sure that platforms are
not allowed to continue to do that we
need to make sure that this information
is not only flagged but it is removed
when it poses a threat to a nation's
security and i think that russia has
been the most culpable but there are
other foreign threats in this regard and
we need to take this very seriously
income ontario time for a short one uh
the honourable member for kitchener
center
thank you mr speaker and thank you to
the member for mount royal for his
always unifying tone
we've also heard tonight from a lot of
parliamentarians the call to waive visa
requirements for those fleeing of
violence and i wonder if the member
would mind sharing his personal views of
the importance of doing so
the honourable parliamentary secretary
um i'd like to thank my honorable
colleague for that question and i think
it would be an appropriate thing to
thank poland for taking in so many
refugees in all the neighboring
countries around the ukraine we
certainly have to make it easy for
ukrainians who are seeking a temporary
or permanent solution to come to canada
and i am certainly open to any
suggestions that would make it easier
for ukrainians to come to canada
resuming debate rapist dubai the
honourable member for king's hands thank
you mr speaker uh it's an absolute
privilege to be able to be here tonight
uh albeit just to have five minutes to
talk about a subject that is much more
nuanced than the time allows but i'll
look to try to give my remarks
proportionate to what we've seen i'd
like to thank the member from etobicoke
center and other colleagues in this
house who have pushed for this debate
it is extremely important that and
timely that we're having it right now
mr speaker i will join the chorus of my
colleagues in this house indeed
individuals around the world who are
condemning and denouncing russia's
egregious attack on ukraine it is unjust
it is unprovoked and indeed it is
against international law
mr speaker this is the largest
mobilization of state to state warfare
that we've seen in europe in decades uh
and indeed it marks a very uh nuanced
and and challenging point vis-a-vis the
cold war i'm 31 years old uh i was born
in 1991
right at the time that the soviet union
was
collapsing
and this of course is very pronounced in
the last 31 years that we've seen this
the images have been horrific
i don't know if words necessarily give
justice to what we've seen
horrific but also inspirational in the
same way horrific in the sense that
we've seen civilians killed we've seen
beautiful peaceful cities that just a
few days ago
we're not dealing with this now being
bombarded uh with russian missiles
uh and bombs and soldiers on the ground
beautiful in the sense that we've how
we've seen the ukrainian people come
together and the resistance from the
leadership of president zielinski
to everyday
ukrainians who are banding together in
such a unified fashion to fight for
their democracy to fight for their
freedom it is truly in every word of the
sense every sense of the word i should
say incredible and inspiring
mr speaker i'm going to take just a
quick moment to talk about our response
the government of canada's response i
think that there would be
uh it would be difficult to find someone
in this house that doesn't support what
the government has done to date indeed
there are calls for us to do more
and i think that those are warranted and
as the situation continues to evolve
we will continue to need to address to
do even more for uk the ukrainian people
whether it be lethal and non-lethal
weapons whether it be the economic
sanctions which we saw today are
continuing to have an impact on the
russian federation
the price of the ruble dropping
significantly the fact that we have
worked to
limit the central bank from having any
access to swift
in those global payments is doing
important work that will not change the
dynamic overnight
but it will be an important piece
i want to take the last two minutes that
i have mr speaker to talk about the fact
of not only do we have to continue to
support ukraine but we also have to
recognize that this is
a change in foreign policy around the
world
and as i mentioned just previously this
is the end of the post-cold war period
no one has a crystal ball on where
things may go mr speaker but the fact of
the matter of russia and china having an
agreement signed just four weeks ago
the fact that china did not vote against
the russian invasion as being
contrary to the principles under the
united nations signals an axis
that i think should have all
parliamentarians indeed all canadians
mindful of that dynamic from a
geopolitical sense
um and and i like other colleagues have
done i just want to provide some
recommendations that i think it's going
to be important for all of us as
parliamentarians and indeed as the
government to consider in the days ahead
one is looking at canada's propensity to
feed and fuel the world i come from a
riding where we're agriculture based mr
speaker we have a tremendous capacity to
feed not only nova scotians but those
around the world how can we start to
incorporate that into our foreign policy
of canada providing healthy sustainable
food uh particularly to our allies and
if those trading relationships change
over time how we can be at the front
line of making sure that we're providing
that similar to what was done uh eight
decades ago during world war ii
we do have to be mindful of our defense
spending i asked the member from durham
earlier uh his thoughts in terms of
mobilization i think probably we're
early yet in that conversation but we do
need to be mindful of making sure that
our military our canadian armed forces
are available and ready
and indeed i would agree with my
colleagues that have been talking about
the arctic whether it be for reasons of
climate change infrastructure economic
opportunities or our sovereignty that
will be an important piece i wish i had
more time mr speaker five minutes is
short for a conversation of this nuance
and this gravity but i look forward to
taking questions from my colleagues
because
is
yes
absolutely
[Music]
this is an important debate and
conversation that we're having here this
evening you know the last few days we've
seen the spirit of my ride in kelowna
lake country stand strong with making
their voice heard in support for ukraine
and i want to be clear that vladimir
putin has created this invasion and
human tragedy it's not the people of of
russia
and the central okanagan is home to
about 14 000 ukrainians
of ukrainian descent
including myself
and i've been in touch with ukrainian
leaders in my community and one of their
asks
was
was to immediately
implement visas
and uh as the official opposition for
conservatives we've actually taken it
even a step further and have recommended
that visa travel from ukraine to canada
that that we eliminate visa so i'd like
to ask the honorable member if he would
be in support of that the member for
king's hands thank you mr speaker i'd
like to thank my honorable colleague for
the question first of all just on one of
the points that she raised in her
intervention the fact that um there is a
separation between the regime and russia
and and russian people and i think we've
seen that uh in the demonstrations uh in
cities across russia i just want to go
on record for saying of course we have
to separate russia uh the russian regime
from the russian people as to her
question on immigration i know our
minister as as he mentioned today in the
house is exploring all options i don't
pretend to be privy to the information
that he might uh in cabinet but i know
that we'll be exploring all avenues to
be able to get ukraine uh ukrainians who
want to come to canada
to be able to get here and any process
to expedite that i certainly support on
this side of the house
questions and comments the honourable
member for south okanagan west kootenay
well thank you mr speaker and i'd like
to thank my colleague for his speech i
just
you know we've heard a lot of
uh questions and
replies about what canada can do we've
heard from the conservatives that we
should
stop importing russian oil which we
don't do now anyways i'm just wondering
what the through you mr speaker what the
member would think about
having the
canada pension plan divest itself of
very
many variable questionable investments
that
can many of them relate to
uh russian oligarch oligarchs
that money that is used to create war
and i'm just wondering if he could
respond to that my colleague from couch
and malhat langford put forward a
private member's bill on this in the
last parliament and it's something that
the government should act on
honorable mayor for king's hands 30
seconds or so thank you mr speaker i'd
like to thank my honorable colleague for
the question i mean the the pension
board is independent of government but i
think now is the time for government to
be looking at all tools available
to limit the ability for
russia for putin for the oligarchs to be
able to finance uh the war that we're
seeing in ukraine so if that was
something that was available and there
was ties i think that that's something
that government can look at uh
particularly given the circumstances
that we're seeing right now
resuming debate representable member for
wellington halton hills
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
the attack on ukraine by the russian
federation ordered by president vladimir
putin
is the first european war
since
the second world war and a serious
violation
of international law and our collective
humanity this attack threatens not only
ukraine but canada because our security
has always been
inextricably tied to that of europe's
canadians know well
the price we paid in two world wars in
europe a hundred thousand canadian war
dead can attest to that
this attack coming on the heels of an
autocratic pact between the russian
federation and the people's republic of
china
threatens the rules-based international
order that has existed since 1945 an
order that canada helped establish
an order that has ensured the longest
period of relative peace and prosperity
in the modern period in order
that if dissolved threatens canada's
peace and security here at home
we support the actions taken to date by
the government of canada
but more needs to be done the government
should expel russian ambassador oleg and
recall canadian ambassador leclair from
moscow
it should seek russia's removal from
multilateral fora such as the g20 and
osce
diplomatic isolation is needed because
diplomacy did not work in fact president
putin used diplomacy for his own
purposes to disinform and to distract
the government should direct the crtc to
adopt a new policy to terminate licenses
of state-controlled broadcasters that
spread disinformation and propaganda
so that russia today rt can be removed
from canadian airwaves as should other
authoritarian state-controlled
authoritarian authoritarian
state-controlled broadcasters here
operating in canada
we must get serious about the
disinformation and propaganda spread by
proxies of russia and china here in
canada
the government should also immediately
implement visa-free travel for
ukrainians wanting to come to canada as
has the european union already as have
member states of the old
union already have done
we must be clear-eyed about these
proposed measures
we must be clear-eyed that these
proposed measures are not going to stop
the invasion in ukraine we must be
clear-eyed that the measures announced
to date by the government of canada are
not going to stop the invasion in
ukraine we must be clear-eyed that a
middle power like canada
can only do certain things
to counter the threat from vladimir
putin and the russian federation
and if we are clear-eyed
there are two things we can do
first
we must understand that energy
is vital not only to our economy but to
our security
russia understands this
canada has not
russia supplies 40 percent of europe's
natural gas and uses this to intimidate
europe and ukraine threatening to cut
off supplies if supplies are cut people
will freeze factories will shutter and
europe's economy will plummet
canada is the fifth largest natural gas
producer in the world but we can't get
gas to europe to assist european
democracies because we can't get
pipelines built
getting natural gas to atlantic
tidewater is vital not only to our
economic interests not only to our
environmental interests but vital to our
security interest
we were an arsenal for european
democracy decades ago
we can be
energy for european democracy today
we must understand that russia considers
the arctic its most important region it
has spent considerable resources there
in recent years
canada like ukraine shares a border
region with russia the arctic ocean we
no longer can afford to take our
security for granted we need a robust
plan to defend canadian arctic
sovereignty and security that includes
purchasing f-35 jets moderate
modernizing norad's early warning system
fixing our national shipbuilding program
joining ballistic missile defense
and closer cooperation with scandinavian
and american allies in the arctic region
mr speaker the world has irreversibly
changed in the last week we must get
serious about the threats presented by
china and by russia and that starts with
treating energy as vital not only to our
economy but to our security and treating
seriously the arctic is crucial
to our sovereignty and to our security
thank you very much
questions and comments questions
the honorable parliamentary secretary to
the minister of international trade
thank you very much mr speaker and i
thank the member from wellington halton
his hills for his intervention and i
know he's a man deeply concerned with
foreign policy what i've remarked upon
is the pace at which the international
community has moved on this issue and in
particular in changing from previously
established positions i'm going to point
them to the example of germany we've
seen in a matter of very
short days or weeks germany rejecting
the nordstrom 2 pipeline germany moving
to actually fund weapons being delivered
by their nation to another foreign
nation in europe and thirdly backing
the elimination or removal of russia
from the swift system of economic
exchanges i wanted to ask him about his
view of the role of canada in prompting
that kind of multilateral cooperation
and how we can keep that level of
multilateral cooperation with nato and
other allies alive and well going
forward once we get past this crisis and
get putin out of ukraine
the honourable member for wellington
halton hills well thank you mr speaker
for the question i think the most
important role that canada can play is
to bring members of the nato alliance
more closely together i think the single
biggest threat that has
uh created gaps between the positions of
the various members of the alliance
is energy i think russia has used energy
as a weapon as a hard power tool
to cow and intimidate central european
democracies particularly democracies
like italy and germany
into
not taking certain positions in defense
of our collective security into our
collect and our collective defense
uh under with the threat of cutting off
the 40 percent of natural gas that
europe uses to heat homes to power
industry
to produce fertilizer for agriculture
and so many other things and so i think
if we in this country can understand
that security is not only essential to
the economy
that energy is not only essential to the
economy but our security
and get pipelines built to atlantic
tidewater we can help
replace russian gas in western europe
with canadian natural gas and bring the
alliance more closely together and i
think that's one of the two most
significant things we can do to
strengthen our collective defense and
security
now we come out to our questions and
comments on the deputy
looking at
especially with respect
foreign
so the actions i think taken by western
democracies today
are going to dictate the actions of the
people's republic of china for years to
come in the indo-pacific region and
that's why we've got to get serious
about our foreign policy we've got to
get serious about our defense policy and
we've got to get serious
about our energy policy and if we are
clear eye about these interests i think
we can defend our values both here and
abroad our belief in freedom human
rights uh democracy and the rule of law
estimate come ontario and just a very
short one for the member for elmwood
transcona
well thank you mr speaker to hear the
member talk about canada's energy you
would think that you know
the canadian government was in a
position to
decide who we export to and who we
import from but in fact the free market
and energy
means that government doesn't make those
decisions so i wonder when the member
talks about a more strategic approach to
canada's energy sector if he means
actually
having
some direction
from govern about about who
who canadian oil producers sell to and
and who canadian consumers buy from
formal member for wellington halton
hills 30 seconds uh thank you mr speaker
thank you to my honorable colleague for
the question
our energy is vital not just to our
economic interests vital not just to our
security interests it's also vital to
our environmental interests the single
thing that the world can do in the next
decade to meet our paris targets to
reduce global emissions is to replace
coal-fired electricity electrical
generation with natural gas-fired
electricity generation it is the single
biggest step we can take to reduce
global emissions european countries many
of them in western europe still rely on
coal and gas to fire their electricity
plants we should be working to replace
that with natural gas a more
environmentally friendly way to produce
electricity in the transition to a
renewable non-emitting future
representative continuing to debate uh
is
that i would never have to face
is
foreign
[Applause]
is
who criticized him
to the east coast
[Applause]
we share a border with russia just as
you can
military supplies
they are proud and effective and let's
give them the needs they need
talk about pipelines
to germany
uh
is
natural resources
that we've all been quite amazingly at
in showing admiration for the courage
and strength of the ukrainian people and
for the leadership of their president
president zielinski and when offered an
exit strategy out of ukraine he
responded and i quote i need i need
ammunition not a ride that was his
response to the americans that's pretty
president zielinski in response to that
kind of plea what we've seen on the side
of the canadian government is we've had
we've had defensive equipment provided
we've had lethal armaments of 7.8
million dollars provided and just today
the minister announced 100 anti-tank
weapons and 2 000 rockets being provided
and i know the member opposite is a is a
defense critic and is very knowledgeable
on this file if you can comment to me on
what that kind of lethal aid provision
represents as a precedent for canada and
what how it bodes for canadian future
military policy in eight of our allies
around the world fighting against
boldface aggressors engaging in unlawful
acts such as vladimir putin thank you
misty
is
thank you very much mr speaker i want to
thank my honorable colleague for his
intervention and part of that i spoke to
some of my constituents just recently
this friday and thursday and many of
them were concerned with ircc in light
of the crisis we have said that while
prioritizing permanent residency
applications and travel documents for
ukraine is a necessary measure the
liberals must not repeat the mistakes
that have been made with that with the
afghanistan humanitarian crisis
they must ensure this work is done
properly with new staffing resources and
immigration levels so that existing
significant backlog for all streams
within ircc is not further impacted do
you agree that the government should be
allocating new resources to ircc in
order to process these new applications
is
foreign
uh
well thank you uh mr speaker i'll be
sharing my time with my good friend the
member of parliament for ottawa west
nepean uh mr speaker i rise today
tonight uh with a heavy heart for the
ukrainian people whose nation has been
invaded by a savage dictator and for all
those who value democracy human rights
and the rule of law like all my
colleagues in this chamber i am seeing
the images coming out of ukraine i'm
watching missiles explode and russian
tanks and soldiers swarm over places i
know in the communities of people i've
met i was an election observer in 2004
stationed in the luhansk region of
ukraine only 60 kilometers from the
russian border this was the first round
of the ukrainian
presidential election rife with
interference by putin and the russian
state that eventually led to ukrainians
rising up in the orange revolution and
the election of viktor yushenko in the
final round of voting i saw firsthand
the massive police presence around
polling stations and the indisputable
evidence of election fraud but i also
experienced the kindness of local
ukrainian citizens at the polling
stations i visited and i witnessed their
belief that they were participating in
an important moment in their country's
history
years later
putin began waging a covert war in the
same region of luhansk as well as in the
donbass costing the lives of seventeen
thousand ukrainians
since that time as an election observer
mr speaker i have traveled to cities
like zapposia and hersan on missions to
help ukraine strengthen its health care
systems where tanks now roll over the
black soil of the countryside that
reminds me so much of my home province
of manitoba
i've spent time in the beautiful
capital of kiev on that iconic square
known as the maidan in the aftermath of
the revolution of dignity that cost so
many ukrainian youth their lives
my mother's family have their roots in
the la viv region where young people in
their late teens and twenties are now
brandishing firearms to fight for their
homeland so mr speaker like so many in
the house today i am heartbroken about
what those families and friends are
going through huddled in basements or
subways fleeing the country or taking up
arms to defend their homeland
ukrainians have been fighting russian
aggression for centuries mr speaker they
have been through some of the darkest
times in history and yes there will be
dark days ahead but what i know mr
speaker is that the ukrainian people
have an indomitable spirit an undying
love for their country their culture and
their freedom they have always prevailed
and will prevail again
let us be clear
vladimir putin's latest act of war on a
sovereign nation is not only an attack
on ukraine but an assault on the rules
based order that has kept global scale
conflict at bay for 80 years
it is an attract an attack on democracy
itself here in canada and around the
world and so we must take a stand
and we with our alleys
allies are indeed taking a stand
vladimir putin strives to divide nato
but in fact he's given nato a renewed
sense of purpose and of unity
with the voices of nationalism and
populism so loud around the world these
days it may seem that there are few who
are willing to defend a liberal
democracy with their whole hearts but
the people of ukraine are showing us all
that those values of freedom and an open
society are worth fighting
and even dying for
the question for us here today is what
will we do to help them mr speaker this
government has taken strong measures to
help ukraine in concert with our allies
and nato partners our government
authorized the provision of lethal
weapons which arrived in full and on
time and more is coming humanitarian
assistance and support for refugees is
on its way as of yesterday canada's
airspace is close to all russian
aircraft operators alongside our allies
we have announced three sets of severe
and coordinated sanctions on russia and
belarus we will continue to impose
severe coordinated economic sanctions as
we call on russia to reverse course
withdraw its forces and choose diplomacy
our resolve to uphold the rules-based
international order and to support the
security of ukraine
of europe and of the world is unwavering
and i wish to end with these words from
mahatma gandhi mr speaker
and he says when i despair i remember
that all through history the way of
truth and love has always won
there have been tyrants and murderers
and for a time they can seem invincible
but in the end they always fall
think of it
always
slava
[Applause]
questions and comments uh the honourable
member of charleswood st james
assiniboia headingley
thank you mr speaker i want to thank my
honorable colleague uh
from fellow winnipegger across the aisle
for his uh very thoughtful speech um
many stakeholders have called for the
expulsion of the russian ambassador from
canada i'm just wondering if the
honorable member could give us our his
thoughts on on on that measure
federal member for winnipeg south
well thank you mr speaker and i want to
thank my honorable friend and and and
colleague from
from winnipeg uh for the for the
question and mr speaker i heard a number
of ministers say today that all options
are on uh the table uh sometimes mr
speaker
even uh you need to talk to your enemies
and and so that is that is a measure i
know our foreign minister will consider
uh carefully and i trust uh her judgment
to make the right decision
um
well
humanitarian crisis in these cities and
towns or through the red cross
on this project
secretary honorable parliamentary
secretary thank you mr speaker i want to
thank my honorable uh colleague from the
block uh for that uh that very important
question as the member mentioned our our
minister of international development uh
made announcement that canada would
match up to 10 million dollars of of of
humanitarian aid and i think he also
heard and we're going to hear from the
parliamentary secretary uh shortly that
he was opening open to
increasing that amount i know the
canadian ukrainian canadian congress
through the canada the ukrainian
foundation
has uh issued an appeal
and we are all working in our our
communities to raise money for ukraine
and i want to say mr speaker while i
have the floor i was i was at a rally in
winnipeg with 5 000 winnipeggers
ukrainian canadians non-ukrainian
canadians standing up for ukraine all
pledging to help
ukraine on the
humanitarian on the military and on the
sanctions side
questioning
the honourable member for victoria
thank you mr speaker and i want to thank
the member for his speech for standing
in solidarity with the courageous people
of ukraine as they fight for their
freedom and for democracy
i asked about visa-free access
before and i didn't get a clear answer
from the government so i'll ask it again
ukrainians don't require visas to travel
to 141 countries including most european
countries the ndp has been calling for
visa-free access for ukrainians for the
past four years does the member agree
that
canada should offer visa-free travel to
ukrainians and
what does the member think is behind
this government's hesitancy to offer
this to the people of ukraine
the honorable parliamentary secretary
well mr speaker i want to thank the
honourable member for uh victoria who i
serve on the environment committee with
and
and thank her for standing with ukraine
mr speaker we heard the the immigration
stand up in the chamber today and again
uh say that a number of these things are
are under cons consideration mr speaker
i think we should do everything in our
power to help uh people in danger make
it to our shores we have a hundred and
eighty thousand people of ukrainian
instruction extraction
and ancestry in the community of
winnipeg and i know that we can welcome
them with open arms they can be in touch
with their culture their language their
religion and uh find find a safe home in
winnipeg
represented by continuing debate the
honourable member for ottawa west
lebanon
thank you mr speaker
it is with sadness
alarm and great resolve that i stand in
this house today to speak at a moment in
history where our words and actions will
have great impact
i had hoped to never be in a position to
speak about war in this chamber
but in the face of open aggression by
putin's russia which is undermining
decades of peace brought about by the
post-world war ii international
rules-based order
canada must do everything in our power
to stop this
democracy on the part of russia against
ukraine is a war against democracy it
also attacks freedom and human rights
and should not remain unpunished we
continue to support ukraine watching
heart-wrenching scenes of civilians
being targeted and killed fleeing their
homes taking refuge in subway tunnels
and stepping up bravely to fight for
their country and for freedom in ukraine
these are scenes we never hoped that we
would see ever again in europe
we've heard interviews with ukrainian
civilians who have expressed a sense of
shock and disbelief
that something like this could happen in
2022 in europe that it could happen in
full view of the world
most of them like us grew up in a
generation that has never known war it
seems unthinkable to them
but mr speaker the unthinkable has
become reality
before entering politics i worked in the
former yugoslavia when i was 29 years
old i spent a year in bosnia-herzegovina
just a few years after the dayton peace
accords
i grew up like most canadians thinking
of war as something that happened to our
grandparents as something that could
never happen to us i took peace and
democracy and freedom for granted
but working in sarajevo it was my peers
those who were my friends who were then
in their 20s who had been at the front
line
eventually my colleagues and friends
started opening up to me about their
experiences
women who'd been raped who'd watched
their fathers and brothers taken away at
gunpoint shot and left in mass graves
young people who would go out for bread
and be shot by snipers
they
told me of atrocities that i can't
repeat here in this house
at the age of 29
i stopped being sheltered by a false
sense that war is something of another
time and another place
i lost my sense of innocence about what
humanity is capable of doing to one
another
the comfort that comes from a veneer of
civilization that i came to know is
incredibly thin
my friends in sarajevo were europeans
they were students they never imagined
that they would see war in fact they
told me that when they marched in the
streets and their own army the yugoslav
national army
took aim and started shooting at them
they didn't run because they didn't
believe it was really happening and mr
speaker i'm seeing the same incredulity
on the faces of ukrainians today
we cannot abandon them because peace is
not inevitable peace takes constant
vigilance and sometimes peace means
fighting to stop war crimes and
aggression and horrors from spreading
if we let it happen in ukraine what does
the world do when russia comes for our
north when other dictators learn lessons
from ukraine we cannot allow the
unthinkable to happen just because we
can't imagine it we must do everything
to stop it right here
right now
from the beginning the canadian
government has stood resolutely with
ukraine we have responded with all the
tools at our disposal through diplomacy
and leadership in the un and with our
allies through sanctions targeting putin
and his inner circle the oligarchs
russian banks and the swift financial
system canceling all export permits to
russia banning imports of russian crude
oil over 620 million in sovereign loans
through renewing and expanding the
canadian armed forces support to nato
through operation reassurance and op
unifier delivering lethal and non-lethal
aids to civilians displaced and harmed
in this illegal war
closing canadian airspace to russia and
expediting immigration avenues for
ukrainians to settle here in canada mr
speaker today ukrainians are not just
fighting for their freedom they're
fighting for all of our freedom
we will not allow putin and his thugs to
dismantle the peace and prosperity that
democracy has brought to the world we
will not waver we will stand with
ukraine slava ukrainian thank you mr
speaker
questions and comments casino come on
tara the honourable member for simcoe
north thank you very much uh mr speaker
and thank you to my honorable colleague
for her intervention and her
contribution to tonight's
conversation uh i've been hearing from
some constituents including one that
actually just passed through one of the
border crossings from ukraine into
poland and one of the things he
mentioned to me was the lack of supplies
and necessities that people at the
border have to support those individuals
you know blankets in cold in the
elements many of these individuals
fleeing are women and children i'm
wondering if the honorable member would
like to comment on some of the
humanitarian aid that we could provide
and if she would support increasing that
support thank you
the honorable parliamentary secretary
thank you mr speaker and i thank my
honorable colleague for that question i
agree 100 with my colleague we've
already seen that we have created the
matching fund with the canadian red
cross of 10 million dollars that is just
a start we've already provided 35
million in development aid another 15
million in humanitarian aid we are
working with other countries not just
for canada to step up further but for
other countries to also step up we are
taking a leadership role and i know that
the honorable member will hear more in
the coming days thank you
yesterday come on questions and comments
uh the honourable member for
south okanagan west gutney
well thank you
mr speaker and i'd like to thank the
member from ottawa west nepean for her
speech
uh my previous the previous speaker my
colleague asked about
why canada doesn't provide visa free
travel for ukraine ukrainians when we
have the largest ukrainian diaspora in
the world and 141 other countries offer
that but what i would like to know is
will the government automatically extend
the visas of ukrainians who are here in
canada now whether they be student visas
or work visas so that they're not forced
to go back to ukraine at this time
the honourable member for ottawa west
nepean thank you very much mr speaker
and i thank my honorable colleague for
that question and yes we are extending
visas for those ukrainians who are here
in canada on temporary visas we are
expediting all immigration
visas we're creating corridors for
canadians for permanent residents and
their families to be able to come here
and i thank the honorable member for his
advocacy because these are incredibly
important moments to be able to bring as
many people as we can to safety and
those who are already in canada to not
have the stress of worrying that they're
going to have to return home thank you
questions
questions and comments
uh
but there are still
to completely eradicate all russian
banks
from ottawa
yes thank you very much uh to my
colleague and mr speaker we have been
working in very close coordination with
our allies with like-minded countries to
be sure that we are standing united in
making sure that that putin that the
oligarchs that the banking system is
going to be completely isolated in the
world you heard the prime minister very
clearly say that we want to remove
russia from the swift system we have a
number of other measures and we are
working very closely with other
countries with our european counterparts
to make sure that there is not impunity
for what is happening right now in
ukraine thank you
time for another question and answer
question i come on tower
there you go the honourable member for
tobok center
thanks very much thanks very much mr
speaker i'd like to thank
the member for her
um not just her remarks but for her
advocacy and her work uh particularly in
her role as
in her parliamentary secretary role and
and going to that i'd just like to ask
her if she could speak to summarize for
folks watching at home what some of the
key things are that canada has done from
a humanitarian perspective and uh needs
to be focused on in in the days and
weeks to come
honourable member for ottawa west nepean
yes thank you very much mr speaker and i
want to thank the member for etobicoke
center for his incredible advocacy on
this and for his untiring and unwavering
work in this area and i would like to
assure the member that in addition to
what i mentioned previously the 10
million dollar matching fund which i
encourage all canadians to take
advantage of and the 50 million dollars
that we recently announced which is in
addition to over 240 million that we've
provided in previous years we are
working
globally we are working with our
counterparts to make sure that we are
providing more humanitarian aid and that
other countries are stepping up as well
thank you mr speaker
zooming debate represented dubai the
honourable member of selkirk interlake
eastman
thank you mr speaker and
you know i'm spending my time with the
member from society white rock and i
just want to thank her for her
leadership as our shadow minister for
national defense on this file on ukraine
as long with the great work that's been
done by my friend the shadow minister
for foreign affairs the member from
wellington halton hills
and i also want to thank the government
for um coming up with the sanctions that
we need uh delivering the lethal weapons
that we've been calling for uh ukraine
has desperately needed and uh there's
another uh a bunch of uh weapons that
were announced today that are to go to
ukraine which will go a long way in
helping them defend their homeland you
know what we've been witnessing
over the last five days
i think all of us find surreal uh and
it's heartbreaking so those of us that
have friends and family still in ukraine
and uh
it it's hard to watch as i'm hearing
tonight that russia has
gotten
way more
aggressive and dropping in
thermobaric warheads
this is a step down from from nuclear
this is a very catastrophic event that's
happening tonight and one that
should be classified as a war crime and
i think all of us here
are keeping the people of ukraine right
now in our thoughts and prayers as this
is playing out um before the world on tv
but
you know it's just
it's heartbreaking and it's something
that it's going to take a long time to
get over but at the same time we've all
been inspired by the leadership of the
government of ukraine and what they've
been able to do and mobilizing their
citizens we've been inspired by the
bravery and courage of just
regular people picking up arms to defend
their country and fight side by side
with their soldiers who have been
courageous and take and warding off the
invading hordes coming across the border
from russia
and you know
it's because of that tenacity
that putin didn't count on he completely
miscalculated on going forward with this
invasion of ukraine
and we've got to keep in mind here why
has ukraine been able to hold off one of
the greatest military powers in the
world
and it's because when you look at the
russian troops they're fighting for a
tyrannical dictator
you know and you took look at the people
of ukraine you know what are they
fighting for they're fighting for
their country they're fighting for their
democracy they're fighting to protect
their freedom
you know they're fighting because they
are trying to protect the european
aspirations that they've had since the
maidan in 2014
and of course they're fighting to
protect the ukrainian culture
and most importantly
they're trying to protect their families
and that's why you see men and women
you know have come up and picked up arms
these are true patriots
now
you know we've witnessed already putin's
revisionist history you know his toxic
rhetoric and we all know from everything
leading up to this that putin is a
pathological liar we should never trust
him and that's why diplomacy will never
work with this man and so we have to do
everything we can to help ukraine and
everything we can to stop putin's war
machine and so there's three things here
that we have to do we have to go ahead
with breaking russia's financial bank
that's why sanctions are important
that's why using swift to target russian
banks that's why we have to replace
russian energy take away the ability for
russia to finance their war machine we
have to keep sending more and more
support to ukraine so they have that
ability to fight back so the lethal
weapons anti-tank the anti-aircraft the
anti-missile systems are what they need
right now so that they can uh continue
on with the fight so more more ammo of
course we don't want to see them run out
of ammo on the street fights that are
taking place today and of course we need
humanitarian aid you know one of the
things that i've heard in the last
little bit is that we can use improved
first aid kits and send those over we
have them here in canada so they get to
the front line we have rule three
hospitals that i know the government
purchased for the purpose of covid
they're still sitting in the containers
let's put them on the c-17s and get
those roll three uh
hospitals over there to deal with the
trauma that's happening and of course we
have to continue on with isolating
russia on the world state suspending
them from the g20 the osce and other
international organizations look at the
end of the cold war
gave us peace evidence but the whole you
know mirage of peace dividends has now
been shattered so we have to do more
um
and spend more on defense we can't do
defense on the chief anymore mr speaker
so we have to step up with our
deterrence and our investments in nato
in norad or arctic sovereignty because
if we don't
dictators despots and tyrants will keep
redrawing international borders through
force and we can't let that to happen we
have to stand with ukraine they are the
front line today mr speaker
questions and comments questions
the honorable parliamentary secretary
the minister of international trade
mr speaker i thank the member opposite
for his vigilance on the ukraine file
for his advocacy and for many things
that we see eye-to-eye on particularly
on this issue
what i've seen at rallies in
my riding at rallies in the city of
toronto some of which the member
opposite has been at is that the support
for ukraine is not just from ukrainian
canadians it is not just from canadians
generally it is from people of all
demographics all ethnicities and
backgrounds i've seen tibetan canadian
constituents of mine uh gathering forces
with ukrainians supporting this fight
against authoritarianism i've seen
taiwanese canadians standing up with
taiwanese flags at these rallies and i'm
wondering if the member opposite could
comment upon the unifying feature that
we've seen amongst canadians and
rallying to this cause and what that
pretends for in general to fight against
authoritarianism going forward now we
can ally against this cause and against
the repression that vladimir putin
represents
the honourable member for selkirk
interlake eastman
yes and i i want to thank the honourable
member for his comments and you know
it's been inspiring watching how
canadians from all walks of life have
come out to support ukraine uh at these
rallies right across uh the country from
coast to coast to coast and you know
i've been out at a few of these now and
in manitoba and ontario and and and
people are in overwhelmingly in support
of ukraine and want to help regardless
if they have ukrainian heritage or not
and as canadians as i say we're all
ukrainian today because ukraine is
fighting for democracy they are fighting
for human rights and they are fighting
for the international rule of law and
you know we have to since ukraine is
fighting for all of us we have to all of
us do everything we can for ukraine and
that's why you know ucc has been
organizing these rallies i encourage
people to get out there and donate i
appreciate the government is matching
donations with the red cross right now
so that we can increase humanitarian aid
and use
organizations like canada ukraine
foundation to help those in need in
ukraine during this unpleasant time of
the war
generally come on tag questions and
comments the honourable member for
edmonton griezmann
thank you very much mr speaker i want to
thank my honorable colleague he's
actually been very wise and as soon as
i've gotten to this place here in the
house of commons i've learned a lot from
this member particularly to ukrainian
issues and i would like to seek this
member's advice again on really in
relation to the russian war crimes that
we're witnessing right now these crimes
are truly
atrocious uh what could rule could
canada play to making sure that we can
hold russia accountable for these war
crimes in particular can canada fund
some of the observations for these
missions thank you very much mr speaker
the honourable member for selkirk into
lake eastman well mr speaker i thank
thank the member from edmonton griezbach
for his his kind words and i also just
want to say mr speaker that you know the
osce has been active in ukraine
monitoring uh what was originally the
line of contract contact under the minsk
agreements one and two and have been
already documenting a lot of the things
that were happening in violation of
those agreements and they are also the
ones that will be documenting all the
war crimes that are happening we need to
make sure that the un of course is
involved in this documentation but there
is a role to play
for nato for the rcmp for the fbi for
other
law enforcement agencies to ensure that
everything that russia is doing right
now
that we can uh hold putin and his inner
circle to account uh including dragging
him in front as i said yesterday dragon
front of the hague at the international
criminal court
castilla come out here questions and
comments the honourable member for barry
anderson thank you mr speaker one of the
conversations that we're having as a
result of this war crime
by vladimir putin is the issue of energy
security in this country
obviously europe is supplied by natural
gas with russia canada is the fifth
fifth largest producer of natural gas
clean canadian energy can be exported
around the world not just used here at
home but the issue of energy security is
becoming critical and i'm wondering if
the honorable member would comment on
that the honorable member for selkirk
interlake eastman well thank you mr
speaker and i thank my uh friend from
barry for that uh
question i can tell you that energy
security for europe uh is something that
is of utmost importance if we want to
ensure that europe doesn't have to be
reliant on russian natural gas
russian oil then let's capitalize on our
ethically produced environmentally
friendly
heavily regulated oil and natural gas
sector and move those products to
tidewater in the atlantic so that we can
easily supply them this has to become an
issue of national importance of national
security and ultimately this is about
international security to ensure that
russia doesn't have the ability to keep
funding their war machine here
dooming and debate the honourable member
for south surrey white rock
well thank you mr speaker
as i stand here tonight as with all my
colleagues in this house my thoughts and
prayers are with the people of ukraine
their indomitable spirit and their keen
sense of patriotism as they stand up to
a ruthless russian dictator in vladimir
putin
as shadow minister for national defense
and a former associate minister of
national defense my mind is also on the
550 canadian soldiers in latvia and the
crew of our frigate hmcs montreal now in
the mediterranean and their families and
what they're going through right now i
think of the reinforcements we're
sending as well
when i was in cabinet we had made the
transition from war fighting in
afghanistan to the afghanistan training
mission these things weigh on your heart
and mind i can imagine that my
government colleagues are not sleeping
that well right now so my thoughts are
also
with uh the ministers who are directly
involved
and the government at this time
close to home canadians pride themselves
on their majestic and largely untapped
arctic our northern our northwest
passage and surrounding areas are
increasingly of interest to china and to
russia for
access to minerals natural resources and
for shipping trade between asia and
europe russian aggression on the
european continent brings home to canada
that an aggressive russia might also be
eyeing our arctic russian aggression
could just as easily take place in the
area adjacent to our arctic coast and
waters and this must be understood by
all canadians
the prospect of further russian
aggression in the north only reinforces
the need for this government to purchase
new f-35 fighter planes without delay
and to cut steel on new warships as we
all know canada has its signals
intelligence listening point post at
alert and an arctic training center in a
command center at resolute bay
this year we are supposed to get our
first arctic port
as operational
in terms of defense capabilities for
this vital region we have our aging
cf-18 fighter fleet victoria class
patrol submarines that can linger near
the edge of the ice cap
a force of canadian rangers and arctic
offshore patrol vessels it's simply not
enough and we must do more canada's
northern warning system needs a major
upgrade of its sensors and its coverage
both north and south to protect us from
a variety of new military threats like
hypersonic ballistic missiles cruise
missiles and hypersonic glide vehicles
all armed with nuclear warheads
russia's
peninsula is one of the most militarized
areas on the face of the planet it is
home to russia's northern fleet and
therefore home to its sea-based nuclear
deterrent in the last few years russia
has refurbished 13 air bases 10 radar
stations 20 border posts and integrated
emergency rescue stations on its arctic
coast
russia has also created a special forces
arctic brigade to be deployed to the
region and has tested a series of
hypersonic cruise missiles and nuclear
powered undersea drones canada must take
our arctic sovereignty and security much
more seriously and not
allow russia's huge military buildup to
go unnoticed and unchecked canada
must push back on the russian government
with several initiatives
and i note in my colleague mention this
that the latest reports say that putin
has used thermobaric weapons today in
kharkiv
these weapons cause massive shock waves
that suck the air out of the lungs of
its victims this is very serious and
there is now a 40 mile long russian
convoy outside the capital of kiev
there's many things we can do we can
expel the russian ambassador we can
recall our ambassador we can give
visa-free access
we can immediately move to remove russia
from the g20 we need to send more help
these concrete actions will send a
message to putin to his oligarchs and
the people who keep him in power that
you can't invade a sovereign state
it's time that they listen to the words
of a great leader mikhail gorbachev who
said the world will not accept
dictatorship or domination we need only
look at the patriotic fire in the eyes
of ukrainians and their president
celeste zlansky and ukrainians here and
everywhere and understand they too yearn
to be free
thank you
questions and comments uh the honourable
member for scarborough guildwood thank
you uh mr speaker and i wanted to thank
the honourable member for her speech i
encountered a privilege to be able to
serve on the defense committee with her
and um it's been a it's been a good
relationship
um
i i agree with her one of our core
points
that the russian militarization of the
arctic is
is uh moving at a furious pace and it is
a
considerable uh concern uh it should be
a considerable concern to every canadian
but i wanted to bring her back to a
question that interested me uh in our
hearings this afternoon
and that is that canada has spent
millions of dollars
in the training
of russian soldiers or sorry ukrainian
soldiers there's a slip
of ukrainian soldiers
and it appears
that
this may be actually paying off
that the resistance being put up
by the
people and the right and the soldiers
to the russian invasion
is really quite impressive
and it may have may have something to do
with the training that's been provided
over the last few years
the honourable member south surrey white
rock well thank you to my colleague and
yes uh we're working away in the defense
committee and in fact
just were there earlier this evening
i think this is a very important point
that you make and i think that something
that all canadians should be proud of
that we have had trainers
in the region for some years now and
no doubt that canadians have had a big
hand in their readiness to fight you
can't put the heart in people they find
that themselves but what we have done
and can do is continue to
train those who stand up for democracy
and who have actual threat like ukraine
has been dealing with now for a long
time
question come onto our questions and
comments
[Music]
should be maintained so does she think
it would be productive to expel the
ambassador instead of maintaining
dialogue thank you
very
rock
well thank you and thank you to my
colleague for your question yes i do
think the ambassador should be expelled
at this point and i do think we should
recall ours yes dialogue is always
important but this is a ruthless
tyrannical
dictator that is now in charge of an
enormous army the second largest
military force in the world
and he has shown over and over again
that he's not interested in dialogue
he's not interested in talking there's
been all kinds of opportunities for that
dialogue and i'm always one who pushes
for dialogue and pushes for talking and
not going that extra step unless we have
to but this person is not listening at
this point and if he shows any
indication of all at all of being
willing to listen there are avenues that
we can make that happen
questions and comments questions
the honourable member for brandon soros
i want to thank my colleague for her
speech tonight as our defense critic and
you know i had the opportunity on the
european
union friendship committee that we have
in parliament to spend a few years as
the standing on the standing committee
of parliamentarians for the arctic
region and my colleague mentioned the
arctic sovereignty that we have as a
neighbor with russia
in our north and i wonder if she could
elaborate just a little bit more in
regards to
the issues around the arctic and our
independence and making sure that it
that we
stand our ground in that area
the honourable member for south surrey
white rock in about 30 seconds okay
thank you mr speaker and thank you to my
colleague for that excellent question i
think on both sides of the aisle
everybody is talking about a need for
norad modernization i don't think that's
news but what needs to be done there's
an expression that that is used and it's
either use it or lose it and as far as
china and russia are concerned they have
been very clear that they want to be the
powers in the arctic whereas canada we
believe
that we should be standing up for arctic
and that means all of canadian
sovereignty we simply have to do more
thank you
resuming debate the honourable member
for etobicoke lakeshore thank you mr
speaker uh i'll be sharing my time
tonight with the honourable member from
london north centre
mr speaker
first i want to start by again thanking
members of the opposition and from all
parties for agreeing to this debate
tonight because
was it not for our you know unity of
purpose
we wouldn't be having this discussion
tonight
i'm rising to speak on an issue that
none of us want to be talking about
it's as simple as that madam speaker
you know we were here
on january 31st
talking about
a possible threat
of invasion of ukraine
just a few short weeks later
we're standing here worried about the
threat
of the use of nuclear weapons
i never thought i would see this in my
lifetime madam speaker
it is surreal in the extreme
for the second time in two years the
world has come together
to fight significant challenges
this time it's the voice are
it's it is to voice our aggression from
one antagonistic individual who is
actively aggressively threatening
democracy
and attacking an innocent nation
mr speaker we join the international
response to russians russia's invasion
of ukraine we must send a very clear
message to russia that its flagrant
violation of the un charter of
international law and of the sovereignty
of territorial integrity of ukraine will
not be tolerated
short madam speaker we stand with
ukraine
madam speaker we've heard a lot tonight
and over the past weeks about how we
have
friends and constituents and colleagues
from the ukrainian community
we all do
and we're proud of that
i want to talk about some of my own
personal experience
i have lifelong friends
anne-marie corello tim walkerchuck john
kozak these are people i went to high
school with madam speaker
anne marie carello who's a friend to
this day sat beside me in grade nine lot
john kozak who i've known since high
school
sent me a text a couple of days ago
thanking me
the government and parliament
for what we are doing to help ukraine
i could feel the emotion
reading the words madam speaker
my friend tim walkechuk
when we were in high school
he would always take a day off
to celebrate with his family and
ukrainian christmas in january
at the time we just thought he was
goofing off and taking skipping a day of
school
i realized later this was an important
celebration for the walkachok family
i realize now
how truly important that is
i think about my friend and our former
colleague
don rosnak
who represents represented the riding of
thunder bay rainy
rainy river or fort william where i was
born
i'm joined tonight by the current member
i went to the prosvita club with dawn
a few years ago when i was visiting my
hometown i was born in thunder bay madam
speaker
it's a club where ukrainian canadians
and canadians
of all walks of life come together to
celebrate ukrainian canadian heritage
it was a moment i remember now
more than i did just a month ago
many of us in this chamber have welcomed
young ukrainian interns into our office
i've spoken of this before in this
chamber
i think of them now
i reached out to one of them a few days
ago i sent him a message
through social media
i simply said are you okay
his response was
i'm fine
but i'm worried about my mother
and my family and my friends
my mother is working in a hospital and
she's now subject to martial law
i gave him my word
that we would do everything within our
power to help ukraine and to make sure
that his family and his friends are safe
i give that word to
all of the interns who
worked in my office and worked here on
parliament hill
madam speaker over the last number of
weeks i've attended many rallies
a member from selkirk has been at a
number of them he's come to toronto
i had the member from thornhill in my
riding on friday outside the ukrainian
consulate the member from berry was
there last week we're all part of these
friendship groups madam speaker
ordinarily we participate in these
things and politically we're tripping
over each other to show our support
for our community more so than the other
party
now
those groups have meaning
the ukrainian canadian friendship group
is the most important group on the hill
at this very moment
i've had occasion to speak with some
ukrainian mps over the past few days
i'm sitting at home
comfortable they're not they're fighting
for their lives
so i am calling for
unity in this house
put partisanship aside
let's lock arms let's work together
government parliament as mps and do
everything we can to stand with ukraine
thank you mr speaker
[Applause]
questions and comments the other member
for stormwater south glengarry is that
correct very much madame speaker and
thank you to my colleague from across
the aisle for his personal speech in
connection to what we're seeing unfold
in the world today and i am with him to
say i believe this house is united
parties are united canadians united and
it's been wonderful to see the number of
countries around the world that are
calling out this horrific invasion and
the tactics of putin for what they are i
want to maybe get him and madame speaker
through you
in the opportunity and questions and
comments we've talked about the military
support and what is necessary for that
but one of the things we don't talk
often enough i believe is something
that's been unfolding the last few days
are the impact of the economic sanctions
that i believe are immediately being
felt in russia and there have been
strong support for removing russian
banks from swift the central bank
and numerous other economic sanctions
that have an impact i'd appreciate his
comments on that of how through
globalization presents some challenges
but here an opportunity to make a
difference in the situation to date
the member for etobicoke glacier
thank you madam speaker and i'd like to
thank my friend for that
very very important question look
everything has to be done i can remember
uh several years ago the the former
member of parliament for etobicoke
center
talking about removing russia from the
swift system
that's being done now
sanctions have been imposed on many of
the oligarchs
they've been imposed on president putin
himself
i believe they are working
i believe we need to do more
and i think i think
and we're working with countries around
the world that's an important message in
all of this people i used the phrase arm
and arm earlier the world is working
together on these things collectively
consistently and together and it is
working
thank you mr speaker
um
[Music]
thank you madam speaker and i genuinely
want to thank you for that question
because
one of the most powerful moments in
question period for me today was when
the first question posed by the block
was
not why haven't you done this why
haven't you done this it was what can we
do to help you
work together
to help stand with ukraine
that was
very powerful and i thank her for the
question tonight so the answer is
talk to us support us
give us ideas there's no monopoly on
ideas madam speaker
and i ask that of not only
she and her party but all the members in
this house because
we have to leave no stone unturned
uh
uh questions and comments the arnold
member for
uh
uh
i want to say south okanagan was
kootenay is that correct and a very
brief question please oh thank you and
i'd like to thank the the member for his
speech
we've heard today how the government has
acted uh on things like extending
automatically extending
work and student visas for ukrainians
here in canada but again we we hear of
the special relationship of ukraine and
canada we have more ukrainian canadians
in canada than there are uh outside
ukraine it's the the biggest
diaspora in the world uh
and yet we don't offer visa-free travel
to ukrainians whereas 141 countries do
and i'm just wondering if if the member
would consider
posing that to his party to
to do for ukrainians at least
temporarily so that they can travel to
canada in this very uncertain time
remember for etobicoke lakeshore a brief
answer please uh thank you madam speaker
the short answer is yes i will i have uh
these issues have been discussed by
myself and all of my colleagues uh i
he knows tomorrow is the first day of
irish heritage month and how important
that is to me ireland did just that last
week uh it is an issue that we are
talking about it is something i would
like to see done thank you madison
uh resuming debate the honorable prime
minister secretary to the minister of
national revenue
thank you madam speaker it's an honor
it's an honor for all of us tonight
to come together and
discuss this i don't even i'd hesitate
to use the word debate it's been a very
good discussion where you've seen a free
exchange of ideas across the aisle and
it is a testament to the fact that this
issue does unify us
even in war madam speaker even in war we
find inspiration and we find so many
examples of inspiration to draw upon
in ukraine
the way that its people and its
leadership have stood up against the
tyranny against the carnage of the
russian regime and its president
vladimir putin
the people of russia it needs to be said
have shown enormous strength and courage
and let us make a important distinction
madam speaker between the regime of
putin
and the russian people
thousands have been arrested thousands
have been put into jail who knows what
fate befalls them madam speaker but that
courage needs to be recognized
and so canada has acted as it must
sanctions against the russian elite have
been introduced including against its
president
canada has come together with other
countries taking a leading role in
helping bring countries together to
block russian banks from the swift
international payment system
canada has also played a leading role
helping to bring countries together to
support placing sanctions on russia's
central bank and that is having an
effect already
it's providing arms in the form of
anti-take weapons and ammunition
and as we saw yesterday russian air
canadian airspace rather has been closed
to russian aircraft
and so
we've contributed but we must do more
madam speaker
i think that we must do more for two
primary reasons
obviously the bond between canada and
ukraine is incredibly strong there are
many reasons for that but i think
migration is the key factor
ukrainians have helped to build this
country there is no other way to put it
that's true particularly in western
canada but it's true in ontario it's
true throughout the country i want to
thank the ukrainian community of london
for its advocacy at this time
it's been a true honor to work with them
to raise
issues of concern in the past few weeks
and i will continue to do that and i
know that members in this house feel the
same way about their community
leadership in their respective cities
and towns
i want to also point of course to the
fact that and i think it was the the
colleague across the way
who spoke probably about 20 minutes ago
who emphasized that
ukraine is now at the front line he used
that word front line and i go for that
madam speaker ukraine is indeed the
front line of the
battle against authoritarianism
it is the front line of where democracy
has been put into question
and we have a choice to make as western
democracies and as elected
representatives
within western democracies on how this
is going to be confronted
do we want to live in a world
defined
by the whim of a despot
or will we stand up
collectively
as individuals in this house
as countries democratic countries who
believe in the rule of law
who believe in sovereignty
who believe in the
rights-based and rules-based order that
has defined
the world
and its international relations
since world war ii
because that is precisely what is at
threat that is not hyperbole that is not
an exaggeration
it is
the reality the reality that faces us
the need for democracy extends though
beyond simply
cherishing it as an inherent value
it is the great stabilizer in our
politics not just domestically but
internationally as well
it is a truism it remains a truism madam
speaker
that no two democracies have fought a
war against one another
there's a whole theory around this
called democratic peace theory you've
told me i have about 30 seconds or so
left so i will i will not go into that
but uh what i
what i will say we can do it another
time matters figure i would love to
but uh what i will say is that
democracy as a stabilizer needs to be
taken seriously for that reason madam
speaker i think we ought to look at more
putting more funding into our defense of
course and helping promote democracy
abroad i was in ukraine a few years ago
and saw the great work that canada has
done in terms of working with ngos on
the ground to promote democracy thank
you very much i look forward to
questioning here
jen comments do you remember from
sherwood park saskatchewan
thank you madam chair i'm hearing
overwhelmingly from people in my riding
those of ukrainian origin and those who
are not about how much they want to help
with the situation on the ground
and there's three issues they've raised
with me that i want to put to the
parliamentary secretary the first is
they want it to be easier for them to be
able to send money to friends and
relatives in ukraine sometimes it can be
very cumbersome to send money to family
members overseas and i wonder if as the
promise secretary for revenue he could
commit to looking into that issue
facilitating those remittances another
issue is canadians who have purchased
supplies or donated supplies uh that
could be useful
for people in ukraine and they want
assistance in getting it over is the
government in the process of sending
supplies able to assist with the
transportation of of donated goods and
then the final issue is clarity for
volunteers those who want to volunteer
and go over to help uh are they able to
do that
what what kind of support could they
receive from the government so i wonder
if the prime minister could come into
those three issues
prominent secretary
well on the last point madam speaker
obviously it's a dangerous time that
goes without saying and so individuals
will have to
think very carefully about what they do
but i know that there is enormous
interest in
not just canada but throughout other
democracies that individuals have
expressed going to ukraine and and
assisting uh in the form of a volunteer
force and we saw something quite similar
materialized uh during the spanish civil
war among other examples but that's the
one that stands out and so if
individuals wish to make that kind of a
contribution that is up to them but of
course i emphasize the point that uh it
is a dangerous situation and individuals
have to think responsibly about their
own safety on the other two points that
were raised i'd be happy to speak with
the the honorable member about the
specifics he didn't point to any
specifics there but uh through uh
through an email or a chat i'd be happy
to hear more about the uh the identified
uh challenges that he points to and uh
and have a conversation
uh question casey
the member for vancouver east
thank you very much madam speaker and i
thank the parliamentary secretary for
his comments uh in my riding vancouver
east in fact today a constituent
contacted our office and basically they
have not been able to bring their loved
ones to canada they've been in fact
stuck in the immigration system for more
than two years uh with the applications
with the backlog now that they're in
this situation obviously there's urgency
the quickest way for
individuals to get to safety with their
loved ones
is visa-free
access why is the government not
proceeding with that and what can we do
as parliamentarians to help the
government move in that direction and
expeditiously bring about visa free for
ukraine
secretary
the question of visa free travel can be
looked at and considered madam chair
but i also point to the honorable member
that the government in fact has acted
proactively going back to january in
fact putting in place a plan to ensure
that
individuals in ukraine that had applied
to canada for work permits for example
would be given support to have their
have their applications approved
individuals in canada on a temporary
resident visa for example or students
will be able to stay longer for obvious
reasons madam chair and so i think that
all of us in this house look at those
measures as entirely reasonable we'll
continue to work together i hope to put
to the government even more ideas but
what can be done to ensure uh a
reasonable approach guides the way
forward but one that has the well-being
of all ukrainians in mind at the
forefront
question the only member of spanish gulf
islands
thank you madam speaker and i've asked
the story but i'd like the opinion of
the honorable parliamentary secretary
will the government be considering going
after the personal assets of the russian
oligarchs including massive homes and
mansions and yachts i know where one
mansion is it's in my riding and i'd
like it to be seized
the honorable parliamentary secretary
well i always appreciate the passion of
the uh of the member and uh especially
on this matter
i think that uh what canada can do and
not to do and i speak uh i speak here as
a as a member of parliament but i join
colleagues i think in this i think we
have to join other countries and explore
exactly what's been what's been
suggested here uh there's no doubt that
the network of oligarchs that is in
russia has many assets abroad if there
are ways to
address that if there are ways to to
seize those and ensure that
they are not put to use by oligarchs who
have surrounded themselves
around the president uh to the detriment
of the russian people then
that then countries can discuss that
work among themselves for uh for
resolution
i've always wanted
we will both
in their solidarity solidarity
saturday
the president
and
in the face
we have no choice
but to support
an attack in fact
because they have shown
ali
inspires us to support them
with
itself
uh
[Music]
and the allies acted
and bigger
he gave us
my colleagues
[Music]
they're calling
refugees
perhaps
questions and comments the honor
parliamentary secretary to the minister
of employment workforce development and
disability inclusion
and i wanted to say thank you to my
honorable colleague for his excellent
speech and for
talking about uh solidarity it's such an
important word solidarity and
it was exemplified by the people of
ukraine over the last number of days
they've really given us an example of
that word and what it means
uh last uh last uh this weekend i had a
chance to participate in a rally in
lansbury park in windsor to come see
those organized by two very strong women
and local leaders
alicia nazarevic and carol guimond
and many people at that rally asked as
canadians what can we do to show
solidarity with the ukrainian canadian
community and so that is my question uh
to my honorable colleagues
men women
[Music]
is
uh
is
[Music]
um
watching what's happening in ukraine the
democracy
democracy
test tested
solidarity
spectacular
foreign
questions and comments you want to
remember for sure what part for
saskatchewan
thank you madam speaker and it's a
pleasure to work with uh my colleague on
the foreign affairs committee and in the
previous parliament to work on the
special committee on canada china
relations
um
there's been a lot of discussion about
the role of misinformation and a
particular concerns about rt
and i think it's important to note that
some of the content we heard in the last
parliament is that there are
various so-called media outlets that are
are state-backed uh coming out of of
russia but also coming out of china that
push misinformation uh and also
sometimes that that uh that feature
atrocities as part of their
uh programming that you have instances
for instance of
forced confessions human rights abuses
that that are that are happening in the
context of of tv production and yet
those are licensed to operate in canada
so i wonder if the member could comment
on the need to yes as many members have
said address the issue of rt but also to
look across the board at uh at
state-backed
misinformation propaganda that's uh
that's coming into canada and whether or
not those entities should have
privileged access to our airways of
course they still exist on the internet
but in my view they shouldn't have the
the privilege of
broadcasting licenses of access to our
airwaves
i was talking about
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
disinformation
this is
uh
uh
[Music]
thank you so much madam chair i'll be
sharing my time with the honorable
member for surrey center
it's a true honor for me to stand in
this house this evening to take part in
this important discussion and debate
that we're having on ukraine on russia's
unprovoked attack on ukraine i want to
start by thanking my colleague from
etobicoke center and all other members
of this house for making sure that we
have the space and time to have at this
important discussion
at a time where when canada is going
through so much our ongoing fight
against covet the unpredictability the
uncertainty and so much change that's
happening in the world today despite all
of this
this unprovoked attack on ukraine is
very much top of mind for canadians and
it's most certainly top of mind for the
residents of my riding of davenport i
firmly stand in solidarity with the
people of ukraine and with its
legitimate democratically elected
government in parliament not just
because i'm a proud ukrainian canadian
but also because i too join all
canadians in condemning in the most
unequivocal manner the unprovoked the
unjust and the illegal attack by russia
and ukraine
two images stand out for me the first
image is president zielinski standing
his ground not leave leaving cave and
sit and saying i am staying we're
fighting for our freedom our democracy
and our country and the images of
ukrainians not just the soldiers but
citizens everyday citizens who've
decided to stay and use whatever is at
their disposal to fight the russians
molotov cocktails taking up arms
whatever's at this
at their disposal their bravery is is
inspiring
the second image for me is this big
country russia a global military power
attacking a smaller nation unprovoked
and the world is has taken notice
because all of a sudden we all feel
threatened because we do not stop this
illegal and unconscious attack on
ukraine who is to stand up for us should
this happen to us this illegal invasion
is against international law and against
article 2 of the u.n charter which says
that there's no nation that is less
sovereign less equal than any other
nation and that no nation has a right to
violate the integrity of another nation
can a zoo an ambassador reminded us in a
speech at the un a few days ago that the
soviet union was actually present at the
drafting of the u.n charter after world
war ii and they are now in breach of the
rules that they helped craft
that they have promised to follow they
know what the charter says they have
chosen to breach it
i am so proud of of of canada stepping
up to do its part we've stepped up to do
our part not only working closely with
our allies
working in conjunction with them and
taking action with our with our
primarily our nato allies but we're also
taking action independently and stepping
up to do our own part
we are taking action in terms of
economic support in terms of providing
defensive weapons lethal and non-lethal
weapons supplies sanctions
on the immigration front we are fast
tracking the applications for ukrainian
refugees we're banning our crude oil
imports from russia and the list goes on
and we will not stop until this attack
on ukraine stops
yesterday
i've i've attended madam speaker
thousands of rallies in my life but one
of the best ones i attended was
yesterday
it was not only well organized but it
was beautiful we can all say the words
we are ukrainian
but yesterday i really felt it and i
really believe that the 30 000 people in
the center of toronto really felt it too
we had leaders from jamaica stand up on
stage and say jamaica is
is ukrainian today we had hong kong
chinese stand up and says we are
ukrainian today i saw members from the
portuguese and the brazilian community
there as well and they were there to
show their solidarity every single
culture
nation we had here in canada was
standing up for ukrainians yesterday the
event ended with the ukrainian canadian
congress telling us to look up there was
a drone that was taking photos above us
because they said that the photos were
going to be sent back to ukraine to show
all ukrainians how canada was there
supporting them thinking of them praying
for them and i hope they did see our
photos and felt our love and support and
our hope for a peaceful end soon because
we want them to be victorious and most
of all we want them we want peace for
the ukrainians who are part of a world
that has seen too much bloodshed for too
many years
and i do hope that we find a way to get
to a peaceful end i hope with all my
heart that there is a way for putin to
stand down
our you and our canadian u.n ambassador
indicated a few days ago that it's never
too late to stop to dialogue and to
negotiate that we are prepared to find a
way to peace to prosperity and progress
for all peoples living in the region
i'm going to end by quoting
we'll have to do that through
questions and comments i i do apologize
uh questions and comments the honourable
member for uh brandon sirs
thank you madam chair i want to
congratulate my colleague for her
excellent speech and i'll give her a
couple of minutes to finish your speech
uh member
yeah
member for davenport oh
thank you madam and i want to thank the
honorable member for allowing me to do
that
i want to end by quoting tara shivchenko
for those that don't know he's a
ukrainian kobazad or the bart of ukraine
and he talked a lot about ukrainian
independence he said love your dear
ukraine adore her
love her in fierce times in the last red
hour struggle
feverly beseech a god for her fight on
and you will prevail
god helps you in your fight for fame and
freedom march with you and right is on
your side thank you madam speaker
[Applause]
questions and comments the owner member
for vancouver east
thank you very much uh madam speaker i
thank the member for her
um speech it was a very moving speech
and i think we all feel it uh it's one
one thing that is important to note that
everyone in this house stand with
ukraine and with ukrainians
in our communities and abroad now i know
that this is something that
is really important for a lot of people
ukrainians don't require visa
uh to travel to 114 countries including
most of europe and ireland just also uh
announced that uh recently as well the
ndp has been calling for this since
2018. why is the government so reluctant
to provide visas free travel to
ukrainians
i remember for davenport thank you madam
speaker and i want to thank the
honorable member for her for her support
her kind comments and her her pushing
for visa i think that our minister of
immigration was very clear today i think
all of our ministers on the government
side have been very clear all options
continue to be on the table i believe
that
we are looking at the visa i also too
hope in the coming days it is something
that we are considering and so i have
great hope that we'll have some good
news in the days to come thank you madam
speaker
questions and comments questions
um i'm sorry i can't see without the
mask
about that sorry ma'am speaker um you
know my uh my colleague mentioned a a
massive rally in toronto and in smaller
communities we had smaller uh rallies
but with no less passion and uh
in kitchener i attended a rally at
victoria park and and we had members of
the ukrainian community as well as from
our small communities members from the
mennonite community standing in
solidarity can the member uh my
colleague explain
the importance of people in ukraine
seeing communities all around the world
coming together uh in solidarity to show
that support
member for
to thank you davenport
speaker and i want to thank the
honourable member for his great question
i think that
you know
i i think that uh so many people come to
this country because they're they are
fleeing conflict and they are fleeing
uh injustice and they are fleeing
um autocratic governments and i think
that
coming to canada we very much value and
appreciate our democracy and our freedom
uh and and our parliament and i think
that it is
it is something that we all value and i
think that we have seen that in rallies
whether it's in small towns and cities
or whether we have seen it in big cities
uh across uh across this nation and i
would say around the world thank you
madam speaker time for a brief question
questions
for saanich gold violence thank you
madam speaker a lot of proposals have
been put forward on top of the very good
actions the government has already taken
one that i think came up earlier today
is that the canadian pension funds are
invested in russian operations we'd have
to amend the canadian pension plan
investment board act would the
honourable member agree with me we
should do so and quickly to divest of
russian investments
the owner for davenport
you know madam madam speaker i'm
reluctant to sort of provide advice to
our pension fund about what to divest or
not divest i will say to you
i'm very proud of not only how the
government has taken action but also
canadians right across this country that
includes businesses small medium and
large
i think everybody has stepped up to say
what is it that we can do i would
encourage everybody to continue to do so
what more can we do how more can we
support ukraine how more can we support
ukrainians
and i think that that's something we all
should be doing in the coming days and
weeks thank you madam speaker
resuming debate
the r member service center
thank you madam speaker canada's ties
with the people of ukraine have
historical roots since well before
ukraine was a sovereign nation this is
why we were the first western country to
recognize ukraine's independence just
over 30 years ago
let me begin by saying that i am with
ukraine
russia's invasion is unlawful uncalled
for and needs to be stopped
we must do everything we can to stop
this unprovoked war
we have developed a strong diplo we have
developed a strong diplomatic
relationship fueled by a passionate and
engaged ukrainian diaspora of over 1.4
million people
the ukrainian diaspora and other
communities across the country are
stepping up to support ukrainians in
need i'm very proud of the sikh
community in surrey who are organizing a
radiothon a telethon with the ukrainian
canadian congress to raise funds for
ukraine
efforts like this are happening all over
canada and bringing people together to
support those affected in this time of
need
throughout history we signed the joint
declaration on special partnership
between canada and ukraine in 1994 which
affirmed our country's shared interests
and desired for international
cooperation
in 2014 thousands of ukrainians stood up
for a democratic future during the
revolution of dignity canada supported
many of the activists human rights
defenders and civil society
organizations that fought tirelessly for
a free and democratic future and we
continue to do so today in response to
president putin's aggressive actions
canada condemns russia's unprovoked and
unjustifiable invasion of ukraine in the
strongest possible terms
we reject president putin's attempts to
rob ukraine of its history
identity democracy and independence
president putin's actions are a blatant
violation of international law including
the u.n charter and they threaten our
shared security
president putin has no interest in
resolving the crisis peacefully instead
he is putting millions of innocent lives
at risk and causing a humanitarian
crisis
in coordination with our allies and
partners
canada has implemented immediate and
hard-hitting sanctions that target
president putin himself and russia's
leadership
key individuals in president pusha
putin's inner circle
key russian banks and financial
institutions as well as export and
export control and sovereign debt
restrictions
by hitting at the heart of russia's
financial sector we're suffocating the
russian regime's ability to fund this
war
to support ukraine's defensive
capabilities canada recently announced
more than 7 million in lethal equipment
and support items to the
ukrainian armed forces this is in
addition to the previously announced
non-lethal equipment on february 27th
the government announced that kendall
will send an additional 25 million worth
of protective equipment to ukraine to
support the ukrainian armed forces
since 2015 we have been helping to
enhance the capacity of ukraine's
armed forces through our non-lethal
military training and capacity building
mission operation unifier and we were
pleased to announce the extension and
expansion of this mission to march
2025. further we also backstop ukraine's
resilience to russian aggression through
offers of financial assistance this will
help support ukraine's economic
stability
we also announced an additional 35
million dollars in development
assistance that will help coordinate and
scale up support for services for those
affected by the conflict particularly
women and mardi gras marginalized groups
furthermore we are continuing to provide
over 10 million per year in peace and
security programming including support
to ukraine's defense and broader
security sector advancing the women
peace and security agenda and countering
this information
in order to meet the needs of those
affected by the conflict we responded
rapidly by providing an initial fifth an
initial 15 million in humanitarian
assistance which has been allocated and
dispersed experienced human rights
partners in ukraine who are ready to
respond flexibly to the situation as it
evolves
this early response is now being
complemented by the launch of a matching
fund and i'm sure my colleague the
minister of international development
will speak more on how canada affirms
our unwavering commitment to ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity we
will continue to stand with the
government and people of ukraine as we
have for the past three decades of
diplomatic relationships thank you
questions and comments the honorary
member for our charles wood saint james
assiniboi headingly thank you madam
speaker
in 2014 after
putin invaded crimea russia was expelled
from the g8
should canada seek russia's uh removal
from the g20 and uh possibly the osce
what is the member's view of that
the honorable surrey center
thank you that's a good question i think
all cards are on the table as you've
seen our government uh this government
has has put the severe sanctions and any
any tool in the tool chest that we can
to persuade or uh to dissuade uh uh
president putin now from
his invasion into the ukraine is on the
tables and i think uh many other g7 and
g20 countries will be looking at that
and as the osce as well
questions
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh thank you to my colleague and uh
thank you for addressing my private
members bill earlier and uh hopefully
you'll support that motion i'm very open
i think if our government can uh work
out the semantics of uh uh of ukraine uh
visas i think uh this country uh in
times of need have has demonstrated that
whether it's syrians uh whether it's a
any any community as miley's in the past
uh uh fleeing from
eastern africa uh any people that are in
need in need of refuge and need of a
place to stay when times of need
we're open to that i'd be very
supportive of our government to
relax conditions so that ukrainians that
need to flee should be able to leave
questions and comments y'all remember
for port moody coquitlam
thank you madam speaker and i thank the
member for the comments around doing
everything they can and certainly the uh
travel visas and release of visas is
very important to the community of port
moody coquitlam and more in belle cara
many families there are very anxious and
awaiting the release of that visa uh
qualification i wanted to talk a little
bit about another thing that the people
in my community are concerned about and
that is the uh the airing of rt uh
russia today on the canadian broadcast
system and i just wonder if the member
agrees that although some of the
suppliers are are removing that from
their airwaves if the crtc
should take the steps to say that no
more rt tv being aired in canada the
honorable surry center thank you i think
that's a good question and actually that
issue came up earlier today i was
speaking to some colleagues from the
opposite side
i think crtc is a
government can't tell them who to remove
but i think there can be direction just
like many of the uh
publishers or broadcasters have removed
them from there i think a direction can
be made and some instructions on what
type of propaganda television should not
be allowed in canada and based on that
policy i'm hoping that crtc will be able
to remove set channels
time for a brief question uh questions
brief question no
oh
the
honourable member for uh sorry uh is it
etobicoke center
thank you thank you madam speaker and
and i i wanted to um thank the member
for his remarks and for his advocacy and
he mentioned during his remarks that um
the sikh community was working with
the ukrainian canadian congress and the
candidate crane foundation to raise
money for humanitarian needs i wonder if
he could tell us about the important
work that they're doing there to help
the korean people a brief answer from
the member for surrey center sure thank
you to the member from etobicoke center
uh yes i was very happy to hear
members of the sikh community led by dr
golzanichima
a philanthropist and fundraiser for the
community stepped up and and has spoken
with several tv stations as well as uh
as radio stations to do across canada uh
telethon and radiothon to raise funds to
help uh those that are in a time like
this in need and to give any financial
and support that we can i'm very proud
of the community in surrey and also
across the country who are helping their
brothers and sisters in a time of need
resuming debate the young member for
kildonan st paul
thank you madam speaker i'll be
splitting my time with the member for
charles wood saint james acidaboy
headingly so i rise today on a very
serious issue the russian invasion of
ukraine we know that russia's attack is
the most serious threat to the
rules-based international order since
the second world war since 1914
madam speaker we have not faced
something like this
and it really threatens the longest
period of relative peace and prosperity
in modern history and as a consequence
of course threatens uh the security that
canada depends
and i think all canadians have seen in
the last number of weeks or days
actually uh the horrific
footage on the ground from ukraine we
know that there's a million canadians
that share
direct routes to ukraine they have
millions of loved ones and friends and
family that are on the ground witnessing
these horrors the casualties are
mounting and it is growing concern for
all canadians i too actually share
heritage from that area of the world
dating back five generations so this
hits very close to home
and just a few days ago actually i saw
an image that just hit me like a ton of
bricks it was a young woman about about
my age she's an opposition member of
parliament much like me in the ukrainian
parliament and she's a new mp as well
and i saw a vid
a photo of her that she posted where she
was holding a firearm and she explained
that just a few days ago in essence she
was a normal legislator just going about
her job much like me
and then within days she's learning how
to use firearms to defend her nation's
security to defend her people
and so to see someone that i relate to
on so many levels
showing that kind of courage
you know it kind of makes you emotional
it hits really close to home i hope that
if i'm ever faced with that kind of
horror that i have half the courage
that mp cure rhodek that's her name from
ukraine and the people of ukraine have
shown in the last
couple of days the resolve they've shown
the determination to protect their
country and their sovereignty it's one
of the most incredible things i think
i'll ever witness in my time in
parliament so i applaud them for their
for their bravery and their courage
madam speaker
and uh you know we and actually i'll
conclude about kira uh with something
she said recently she said we will now
have a generation of children
who will know what war
is
if that doesn't hit close to home madam
speaker i don't know what is what does
and the conservatives we very much
appreciate the efforts from the liberal
government in recent days we do wish
that uh they would have equipped ukraine
with uh military tools far sooner but
we're very happy to see the efforts
they're taking now and we have a number
of things that we've proposed that could
be taken immediately to support ukraine
and also things that we need to
seriously be talking about in this house
and across the country to ensure not
only the sovereignty of ukraine and of
europe but also canada here at home and
so in the immediate term we've called on
the government to
declare the ambassador uh to canada from
russia persona non greta so it's time to
kick him out of canada madam speaker and
it's time to recall our ambassador
from russia that's something we can do
immediately that's something we can do
today
we've also asked the government to
ensure they are banning all russian
propaganda from our airways and i do
believe that this is starting to happen
as well that's great to see but it needs
to happen quicker and again needs to
happen now there's no place for russian
propaganda
on canadian airways
we also need to you know with russia its
actions they they have they have no
right to be on international
organizations like the g20 for example
or organization or the organization for
security and cooperation in europe it's
time to kick them off that
they don't have no right
to be on those uh international
organizations madam speaker and also to
support the ukrainian people immediately
we can see the government implement a
visa-free travel regime so we can bring
ukrainians to safety as soon as possible
i have many constituents in my riding
who have family there we need to bring
them to safety
and then the last two things and i hope
to continue some of this in my question
and answer period but we've proposed
that the government must serious take
very seriously and bring forward a plan
to focus on arctic sovereignty and
security remember we share a very very
long arctic border with russia we're one
of the largest land masses in the world
and most of it is the arctic
russia has 40 nuclear-powered
icebreakers that are equipped with
torpedoes
do you want to know how many canada has
madam speaker zero we have zero there
are serious investments that need to be
made and i'll look forward to concluding
my remarks in the question period thank
you madam speaker
questions and comments questions
the owner member for vancouver east
thank you very much uh madam speaker i
thank you thank you to the member for
her speech um one of the issues that
that i'm very cognizant of is of course
the variety of measures that the
canadian government needs to put in
place to support
ukrainians and with respect to
immigration
the government has announced that if
some effort is being made however we
also just learned that the government is
not putting additional resources to
support that work within ircc if we
don't put additional resources into it i
fear that the backlog within ircc in
other streams will just escalate as we
have seen so what is the members
thoughts with respect to the government
needing to put additional resources to
support immigration measures uh to
support the people of ukraine
remember killed in saint paul i think
the member for the question we work
together an immigration committee and i
very much support seeing the government
put more resources into ensuring we have
a visa-free regime that we can bring
ukrainians to canada be reunited with
their family to be reunited with
canadians to bring them to safety that's
something we can move forward with
immediately the government has the
resources they can put that in place in
the coming days another thing that we
can do to support ukraine and all of
europe is to ensure our pipeline
capacity takes canadian gas to tidewater
so we can offset europeans dependence on
russia for gas they depend 40 percent of
european gas is dependent on russia
right now so what does that do to
countries in europe that are looking to
support ukraine well they're in a vice
grip from russia because of the energy
that they provide those european
countries so we can easily offset that
by getting our resources to tidewater
and supporting the security of energy to
our european allies madam speaker
questions and comments questions
oh sorry i'm going to blow it here
the
member for
storm out dundas south glengarry yes
not a problem
it's a long riding title i don't blame
you uh thank you for recognizing me to
my colleague for for her speech uh well
done as always and she was referencing
in her previous intervention there
talking about the economic pressures
that we can put on ukraine we've seen
that
for the global community the last couple
of days and i believe in the coming days
we're going to see even more pressure
and more success through that i'd like
my colleague to take the opportunity to
talk about some of the economic measures
been done today but elaborate further of
where russia for years has used their
energy sector
as a war machine funding their war
machine how can we stop that how can we
send a message and set that precedence
that we're not going to accept in a
global community
member for killtown in st paul i'd like
to thank the member for the question
thank you very much well one of the
things we can do immediately is move to
remove russia from the g20 from other
international organizations that they
have no place having violated the
international order they have no place
on those international bodies
again i mentioned that we can expand our
pipeline capacity to ensure we're
offsetting the european dependence on
russian gas we have gas if only we can
get into tidewater to get it to europe
this is something that we should be
hearing today from this government that
they're silent on as far as i'm aware
i'd like to hear more from them on that
but another thing that i'd really like
to bring into this is that recently um
russia really as we know is a nuclear
superpower and it recently has raised
the level of its own level of nuclear
readiness pardon me so it is critical
that we hold president putin and the
russian government accountable for this
gross violation of ukraine's territorial
integrity and sovereignty but also at
the same time we need to ensure we are
avoiding it all costs any escalation or
accident between nuclear superpowers
that is paramount madam speaker
time for a brief question questions
the honourable member for spanish girl
violence
speaker and my honorable colleague i'm
going to leave aside the wisdom of
wanting to send
natural gas or any other fossil fuels to
europe but ask if on reflection
anything can be done quickly given that
with all the supports in the world the
the trans mountain pipeline which was
originally booked for a 4.5 billion
dollar cost is now estimated to be a
21.4 billion dollar cost and we'll be uh
years behind schedule it it's not a
viable solution is it i ask the
honorable member through you madam
speaker
answer from the member for kill dylan is
saying what i think is not viable is
having europe dependent on russian gas
having our country's own sovereignty and
security at the whim of 40
nuclear-powered weaponized icebreakers i
don't really care about the cost we need
to ensure that security of canada is
first and foremost the priority of this
federal government madam speaker
resuming debate the young member for
charles woods st james assiniboi henley
thank you madam speaker i rise today
with all members of this house to join
in solidarity with the people of ukraine
this unwarranted attack on a free and
democratic country highlights how our
security is inextricably tied to that of
europe nato and its allies understand
the danger of a belligerent russia that
seeks to redraw the international
borders of europe by force
might cannot
make right madam speaker those
dictatorial thugs who think they can
take other countries by force now know
the price
they will pay
canada must strengthen our own defenses
and renew our commitment to the nato
alliance
madam speaker let us take pause and note
the extraordinary courage of the
ukrainian people they've galvanized the
spirit of the entire world they will
never give up
and we will always be with them
defying the expectations of its collapse
ukraine has kept going they've kept on
fighting as we speak here
at this very moment
history has found the ukrainian
president and his courage is remarkable
to witness president zielinski
has been subjected to the most intense
stress test of character putin in his
hubris has made a tremendous error
never underestimate the strength and
courage of those that fight for freedom
over tyranny
never
underestimate the will of the free world
to defend those who fight for freedom
and never assume that your own citizens
will support a leader that would reign
such terror on their ukrainian brothers
and sisters
this is a conflict entirely of putin's
own making and every drop of blood
is on his hands
now it is clear he craves war and fears
freedom and democracy putin thought that
in seeking an invasion nato would just
hand over ukraine
yet even in that scenario madam speaker
all they could have gotten was internal
chaos
and civil strife
madam speaker i support our leaders call
to expel the russian ambassador the
ambassador should be expelled
right now
and at this government should recall our
country's envoy in moscow our leader is
also correct that russia today needs to
be taken off the airwaves foreign
state-controlled broadcasters have no
business spreading their misinformation
in canada and i commend rogers and bell
for making the decision to remove them
parliamentarians cannot ignore what is
literally and figuratively fueling
putin's power
oil and gas we can't ignore that madam
speaker
the liberal government has failed to
recognize that canadian oil and gas is
vital is vital to canadian and european
security we need to get new pipelines
built to tidewater to displace russian
natural gas russia supplies 40 percent
of europe's natural gas if supplies are
cut people won't be able to heat their
homes industry will shutter and europe's
gdp will plummet
in buying russian oil and gas europe has
been filling putin's coffers paying him
the money he needed to build up this
brutal army that he's now using to
savage his neighbor
no more i say madam speaker
no more can putin impose tyranny and
expect to enjoy the economic spoils
of the free and democratic world no more
can a leader who has behaved as
irrationally as putin has have that much
power
over its na neighboring states
no more
will we idly stand by
canada is the world's fifth largest
producer of natural gas but we can't
expose export gas to europe to assist
european democracies because we can't
get pipelines built
this liberal government must get serious
and realize our energy sector is not
only vital to our economy but vital to
our security and the world's security
moreover conservatives are calling on
this government to step up for freedom
and democracy by allowing visa-free
travel from ukraine to canada madam
speaker our red lines must be clear nato
must stand fast article 5 must be
sacrosacked
madam speaker i'd like to close with the
words of president kennedy as he
addressed the nation on october 22 1962.
he said my fellow citizens let no one
doubt that this is a difficult and
dangerous effort on which we have set
out but the greatest danger of all would
be to do nothing the cost of freedom is
always high but americans have always
paid it our goal is not the victory of
might but the vindication of right not
peace at the expense of freedom but both
peace and freedom here in this
hemisphere and we hope around the world
god willing that goal will be achieved
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
boy hitting me let me be perfectly clear
madam speaker mr putin's word is not
worth the paper it is written on thank
you
uh questions and comments questions
the honor member for brandon sirs
thank you madam speaker and i just
wanted to congratulate my colleague on
his excellent speech this evening and
i've talked to uh or asked other members
of the house tonight about the issue of
canadian sovereignty in our arctic and i
know that my colleague coming from
winnipeg has a
heart and soul on that with the research
that we have in the university of
manitoba i wonder if he could just
elaborate on
the fact that we are a neighbor to
russia and what we can do to defend
ourselves in that area
and that uh the honorable charles wood
st james assiniboine headingly well i
thank my colleague for the question
because i think what we all recognize
here today is that we have woken up to
the tyranny of putin's russia
and that affects the entire world and
canada is not immune to that we share a
border with russia mr putin uh just the
other day spoke about raising his um his
uh nuclear arsenals alert we have to
wake up to the reality of putin's russia
and do whatever we can to protect
ourselves protect all canadians
including protecting the sovereignty of
our arctic presence
the
honorable member for spanish golf
islands thank you madam speaker and the
honorable colleague from charleswood st
james assiniboine headingly
it's kind of a personal reflection from
other
contexts that hasn't been mentioned
tonight that i find it so extraordinary
that president zielinski is also a
jewish leader in a country that has been
known in the past for anti-semitism and
i wonder if the honorable colleague
would have any reflections on that
i remember charles woods saint james
it's in the boy handing me
well again i think uh president
zielinski has shown us all what true
leadership
is madam speaker
and i i think we have to give him all
the support
that that we can and um and and wish him
uh well in his endeavors to protect his
country and i would only hope that if
canada ever faced a similar situation
that our prime minister would act uh in
in the same vein thank you
time for a brief question the member for
tobacco center
thank you very much
thank you very much madam speaker um i'd
like to thank the the honourable member
for his his remarks
um and really
say that i'm grateful for the for the
support and that that many of the
members on on
on the official opposition have shown
for the steps the government has taken a
lot of unity has been shown and i think
that's really important at this time i
just wanted to ask you know a lot of the
measures that canada and other countries
have instituted have been around
providing ukraine with military support
like the announcement that was made
today around the weapons but also
economic sanctions in a variety of
forms and i'm wondering if if he could
speak to whether he agrees with those
measures and
what if any impact he thinks those
measures are having to help the help
ukraine
yeah charles woods st james assiniboi
henley a brief answer please well you
know madam speaker i have to say in my
brief time here i was elected in 2019
i've never seen the house come together
in such a way and it's it's really
wonderful to see and
i think we work together i sit on the
foreign affairs committee we've been
working together as a team to
promote sanctions magnitsky sanctions
sanctions under the sema legislation and
the whole world has come together to
work in lockstep to do the same thing
because we recognize that this is a
fight of freedom over tyranny and it's a
line that simply cannot be crossed
resuming the gate
resuming debate the arnold prominent
secretary to the government house leader
thank you very much madam speaker i'll
start off uh by just mentioning that
i'll be sharing my time with the member
from saanich gulf islands
madam speaker a lot has been said this
evening uh with respect to the various
different measures that canada has put
in place to help ukraine and indeed
come together with the world in terms of
our response to the
outrageous aggression that's coming from
russia right now and in particular
putin i think it's very important to put
on the record at least from my
perspective i don't believe that
the russian people
are bad i just think that vladimir putin
is a monster
and
you know we've talked about the various
different things that have been put in
place whether it's sanctions whether
it's money
that's flowed to ukraine whether it's
the different um
personnel that's been sent over as part
of operation reassurance what we know
from
you know the history over the last
decade or so of canada's involvement is
that there's been an opportunity to
really help ukrainian
people provide
prepare for uh what has unfortunately
come
you know
what i really want to talk about in the
short amount of time that i have madam
speaker is the incredible resolve
that we've seen come from ukrainian
people the member from selkirk interlake
eastman uh talked in his speech about
the the manner in which ukrainian people
were responding to what's going on and
he compared that uh to the manner in
which we are witnessing
uh russian uh troops uh engage in you
know i the member from selkirk interlake
eastman specifically said
when you are under a dictatorship and
you're being told what to do you're
never going to have the same resolve as
those that are fighting for something
that
they believe in and that they so
passionately are chasing after
it reminds me
of
when i was on the defense committee and
i traveled to
ukraine as part of a study that we were
doing on operations unifier and
reassurance
the member from selkirk interlake
eastman was there as well and he would
remember that at one point we went to
meet with the new police chief of kiev
we met him in
the center of town and he couldn't have
been more than 35 37 years old
and it was remarkable to listen to this
young individual talk about the future
of ukraine and indeed what we know is
that going back to 2014 and the
revolution that took place it was led by
future generations it was led by the
youth it was a youth movement that
changed the course of ukraine back in
2014
and what we saw what we what we heard
from this uh police chief this young
police chief is he basically told us he
said you know
things were done differently
in the past remnants of the former
soviet union still existed in ukraine
and they literally had to fire almost
every police officer who was over the
age of 40 just because
they did things differently and that's
not the future that the younger
generations wanted
they knew what they were going for they
knew how to chase after it and they knew
what had to be done you know if you want
to talk about the resolve of the
ukrainian people versus the resolve of
those that are under a dictatorship
look no further than the former
president one of the former presidents
of ukraine um
it was uh yanukovych who was president
during the uprising
and what did he do
he fled the country
as a result of a youth
revolution
he literally got up and left because of
what was going on and you compare that
to the president of ukraine today
zielinski
he won't go anywhere he's steadfast in
his commitment to staying with his
people and staying in ukraine to see
this through to the end and you know
if nothing can show the difference
of what the member from selkirk
interlake eastman was talking about in
his speech more than just the approach
in the two different presidents one that
was basically a puppet of putin and one
that is for the people
it's that
and so
i genuinely believe that regardless of
of what happens regardless of the wars
that are are fought today the battles
that might be won or lost today at the
end of the day ukrainian people are
going to get what they want they're
going to get this freedom because
they've been fighting for it for a long
time they have the resolve to see this
through to the end and it is clear that
they will win their freedoms at the end
of the day regardless of these temporary
uh um impositions that putin is putting
in the way thank you madam superman in
comments yeah i remember killed dylan
and st paul thank you madam speaker i'd
like to thank the member officer for a
very civil discourse tonight is really
great to see i think this is probably
the most civil i've seen any debate in
the house in my few years as a
parliamentarian so i thank him for those
efforts i would like to ask the member
of what his thoughts are on
european dependence on russia for gas
what does he feel the impact of that is
uh on europeans and their ability to
support ukraine and does he feel that
canada has a role to provide energy
resources to europe
the honorable member for the
parliamentary secretary well madam
speaker i think that the member from san
jose golf islands answered this very
well through her question which
basically indicated that even if canada
was to try to take on that role it would
be a long time in the making it's not
something that's going to be able to
correct and help immediately should we
ensure that dependence uh on a nation
like russia in particular for europe
should we be doing what we can to assist
in ensuring that that doesn't happen uh
yeah absolutely but we can also do what
we're doing now which is putting in
tough sanctions on russia
to make sure that they are crippled to
make sure that putin is crippled to the
point where he is unable to do anything
globally
we know that that our economy is so
dependent on the global movement and
interchanging of of goods and services
throughout the globe if we can bring him
to his knees in this regard we certainly
will um be doing the world a favor and
in in my opinion helping uh europe as
well
uh questions and comments the owner for
south okanagan with kootenay
thank you madam speaker and i'd like to
thank the member from kingston and the
islands for his speech
and you know the risk of sounding like a
broken record here in canada we have the
largest ukrainian population in the
world outside of ukraine
141 countries the world offer ukrainians
visa free travel yet canada does not
and at this time especially
is there any way that the government can
at least temporarily give uh ukrainians
the right to visa free travel so that
they can get here as safely and quickly
as possible
parliamentary secretary
two things very quickly madam speaker
the first is that we certainly have put
in place uh and i'm sure that the
members aware of it various different
measures for those that are already here
to make sure that their stays are
extended whether it's a student visa or
people that are traveling to ensure that
they don't have to go back to ukraine
right now but to the point that this
member and others have been bringing up
today about visas uh you know i haven't
given it much thought yet personally
when i think about it i think yeah you
know that makes a lot of sense i also
know that you know these decisions are
made by uh weighing a whole host of uh
different variables uh i i haven't heard
the other side of it uh but i certainly
think that the question that's being
asked is a good one because uh it
warrants discussion and if it's one way
that we can assist and it proves to be
in a safe and effective way
then i personally would not have
anything against it
questions and comments questions
the member for saanich golf islands
thank you mr speaker and i i i echo the
comments of the member honorable member
for kildona and saint paul's it is
certainly a wonderful thing when we can
come together and unify around common
cause which is to defend the people of
ukraine against an aggressor that i
don't think is a nation of russia it
increasingly seems to be
its leader who was unconcerned with the
fate of his own people as well as the
people of ukraine i asked the honourable
colleague if he has any thoughts on how
we can reach out to the people of russia
who are bravely standing up in peace
marches to encourage them to fight
against putin
i promise your secretary
thank you for that question to the
member from saanich gulf islands and it
certainly is encouraging to see people
that are standing up and going out and
protesting in a country that we know
things can happen to those that are very
loud and vocal about their opinions yet
they're still doing it so i think that
is even all the more inspirational about
it what can we be doing i think we can
be giving them the tools to make sure
that their voices are heard i think that
we can be communicating through various
different technologies that we have
today to make sure that the right
information is getting forward when
president zielinski specifically spoke
to the russian people in russia
russian i think that was incredible but
we know that's not going to be played on
rt
russia today we need to make sure that
we're doing our part to get messages
like that in front of the russian people
because they are being suppressed and um
the manner in which that they're being
uh um
pushed down is this exact same thing
that putin wants to do to uh ukrainians
so whatever we can do to make sure that
that uh gets through we should be doing
thank you madam super
resuming debate
the honor do you remember for sign this
golf rollins thank you thank you madam
speaker
i rise tonight in this debate of
historical importance because the world
has changed and i know that's an
overused phrase
but we're not in the same place we were
in a week ago
because vladimir putin is even
threatening the use of nuclear weapons
after
an on an illegal appalling aggressive
assault on a democracy that didn't
threaten him
one can look back and say what should we
have done at different points in the
history of the relationship with
what is the former soviet union and the
west
when the soviet union fell i remember
wishing that we had launched that we
would at that in the moment wishing
where's the marshall plan
what are we going to do for the former
states that were once the ussr russia
and its neighbors clearly they need help
we didn't offer it we were in a
triumphal mood of western
capitalist
hegemony and we just abandoned the
people of russia we essentially
abandoned them to organize crime
it capitalism maybe democracy not much
but a lot of kleptocracy of natural
resources and the people of russia had
reduced life expectancy in this time and
still to this day their quality of life
having gotten rid of the ussr went down
that should never have happened we
should have been thinking we should have
been and some of us were wishing for the
peace dividend we've been waiting for
the peace dividend when we'd stopped
putting so much
money in budgets in the united states
and all around the world into the
military-industrial complex we don't
need it anymore there is no more ussr
but no we found other enemies we decided
we didn't need a peace dividend we kept
investing in war
and we missed the chance this is
probably the biggest chance we missed
because mikhail gorbachev
and ronald reagan started down the path
of nuclear disarmament global nuclear
disarmament and here we stand as canada
we have a treaty to abolish nuclear
weapons and canada isn't even a
signatory
we need to pay attention to this but we
thought that nuclear weapons were in our
rear view mirror they're not
they're not they're in stockpiles and
they're in missiles and we need to pay
attention again to the threat of nuclear
war
in tonight's debate which has been
mostly very much on the same themes i
need to address occasional there has
been more than occasional uh misplaced
notions that now we need to build more
pipelines that europe needs more fossil
fuels but if we look at what the leaders
in europe and even in ukraine are saying
we do not hear these calls
in fact the energy commissioner for the
european union kadri simpson said this
the crisis in russia means that we have
to quote boost renewable energies and
energy efficiency as fast as
technologically possible
what does germany say well germany just
asked their biggest carbon project with
russia nord's dream 2 pipeline has been
cancelled and what does the economy and
climate minister who happens to be green
party co-leader robert haybach say in
schultz's government now is the time to
accelerate and shift to renewables it's
being a petrol state and having
dictators of petrol states that makes
the world less safe
some of the big oil companies are even
saying they have to get out of russia
shell and bp have pulled their projects
out of russia but look at exxon it's
still in there let's assess exxon in
every way we can why it's still invested
in russian oil and gas and the french
company total in energies still invested
in russia but the most compelling
information about what should we do
about fossil fuels in this crisis
is to listen
to the head of the ipcc
ukraine delegate the scientist dr
svetlana klakovska who said this quote
human-induced climate change and she
said this while bombs were falling near
kav she said human-induced climate
change and the war on ukraine
have the same roots
fossil fuels and our dependence on them
we will not surrender in ukraine and we
hope the world will not surrender in
building a climate resilient future
close quotes i want to thank our deputy
prime minister we are unique in the
world that our deputy prime minister
happens to be an expert on russia she
wrote the book sale of the century about
the kleptocracy and organized crime that
took over the former ussr i know that
her background and with the unique
honor of being personally banned from
russia by vladimir putin equips her well
to lead the fight to get the swift
financial resources taken away from
russia my time is up madam speaker i
look forward to questions
the owner member for south okanagan
well thank you madam speaker and i'd
like to thank the member for spanish
gulf islands for that speech
i knew she was going to be speaking
about fossil fuels but i'm very happy
that she brought up the nuclear weapons
and canada's inaction in the nuclear ban
treaty ban uh but i i would just like to
give her some more time to talk about to
respond to some of the conservative
calls for canada to export more oil
to europe or
gas to just some of the
the logistical problems uh that faces
that
uh being even contemplated
i don't know member uh for spanish
girlfriends well thank you madam speaker
to honourable colleague from south
okanagan west kootenay
if the ukraine if if zelinski was saying
canada send your oil i'd have a really
hard time saying no i don't think i
could say no to president zaleski for
anything i am so inspired by him but
that's not what he's saying it's not
what germany's saying it's not what the
eu is saying it's what alberta is saying
and i think taking advantage of a crisis
to promote your own product is not a
good look
questions and comments uh the honor one
for storm dandas south glengarry thank
you madam speaker and uh thank you to my
colleague for her intervention here
tonight and i i want to build on the
comment from the ndp and talking about
that and i mean the line is the
logistical challenge of canada providing
for example natural gas to europe but
the other reality the logistical
challenge we have and that europe faces
is they are reliant on russian energy at
this point so i think part of the
opportunity is we look at the
perspective we have as canadians of the
attention to uh do i think from a human
rights perspective from a global
perspective as we're seeing here our
record on the environment our record of
the international community stands much
better than russia so i just like the
member from sanders gulf islands to talk
about the logistical reality of where uh
russia uh you know kind of has uh europe
uh caught in a bind when it comes to
natural gas and canada not play a better
role thank you spanish golf islands some
of the commentary that i've been looking
up today of the german discussion about
what to do now they're cutting off
russian natural gas is
discussions about the fact that natural
gas that comes from fracking has the
same carbon footprint as coal so they're
actually discussing whether in the short
term they should use a bit of coal to
bridge till they get to renewables which
is the only reason they were going to
use natural gas obviously uh it the the
the propaganda around natural gas has
been very effective because i know a lot
of people honestly think it's a low
carbon fuel but when you look at the
whole upstream
fracking and massive releases of methane
it's it's a climate killer
uh
if
definitely send them back
brief uh uh question the problem
interest secretary the government house
leader thank you uh madam speaker given
the discussion of what's been going on
about uh
oil and canadian oil and gas and this
member's comments about it i'm wondering
if she can give us uh or give me her
perspective on what she thinks is more
realistic that
a pipeline that is supposedly now four
times as much as it was before it's
going to be built and provide
this sustainable
carbon fuel carbon-based fuel to
europe or if there's going to be a
transition
towards more renewables and
electrification what's more realistic of
happening
a member for central finance a brief
answer there's what's realistic and
what's necessary the intergovernmental
panel and climate change report just
today reinforces that we don't have a
choice if humanity wants to survive
within a climate that sustains our lives
and human civilization we don't have a
choice we get off fossil fuels as
quickly as possible and for the
governments of europe they seem to see
that this is an opportunity to move
faster towards renewables not to back up
into the fossil era
resuming debate the honourable member
for edmonton griezbaugh
thank you very much madam speaker and
tonight i rise in this place only months
after my arrival in this house to
discuss a matter of utmost importance
and true urgency albeit i wish this day
would never have come
but we almost rise to this occasion
a moment in our history
a moment for unity and a moment for all
of us to stand with ukraine at this time
in their hour of most need
prior to moving to edmonton i grew up in
a small metis community in alberta
called fishing lake
like many who know that part of our
province well
they know that there is largely two
groups
many indigenous like myself and
ukrainians our neighbors for over 100
years
the ukrainians are the very same who
paint our fields gold each summer a
truly remarkable sight to see ukrainian
families were some of the very first
people to settle
treaty six territory
and they were here long before even
alberta was a province
a true example of the spirit and intent
of treaty
many of these friendships still endure
today
ukraine has shocked the world with its
heroic resistance against putin's war of
aggression
president zielinski and hundreds of
thousands of ukrainians have bravely
resisted
the russian attack even in the face of
overwhelming odds
but despite the brave efforts of
ukraine's military the situation on the
ground is dire
especially for the many civilians who
are caught in the crossfire
as we speak
russian artillery and missile attacks
are pounding ukraine cities day and
night
kiev's
kiev ukraine's capital is under siege
its three million inhabitants have been
forced to take shelter in their homes in
kiev subways and in improvised bomb
shelters
according to the u.n secretary general
there are credible amounts of
residential buildings
civilian in other civilian
infrastructure and non-military targets
sustaining heavy damage under russian
attack
as he emphasized in his speech today
quote this escalating violence is
resulting in civilian deaths including
children
the people of ukraine are no stranger to
russian imperialism putin's invasion is
the latest in a long line of aggressive
and illegal attacks on russia's uh sorry
on ukraine's sovereignty
the escalating tactics that the russian
military are employing against ukraine's
military and civilians alike are in
keeping with a long line of atrocities
as
as amnesty international secretary
general recently put it quote the
history of russia's military
interventions be it in ukraine or syria
or its military campaign at home in
chechnya is tainted with blatant
disregard for international humanitarian
law
the russian military repeatedly flouted
the laws of war by failing to protect
civilians and even attacking them
directly
russian forces have launched
indiscriminate attacks
attacks used banned weapons and
sometimes
deliberately targeted civilians and
civilian objects a war crime
while russia's government and military
and above all its president deserve our
complete condemnation it is vital that
we recognize the russian people
are far from united in this war
many of them are showing incredible
bravery by standing up to putin and
saying no to war
tens of thousands of ordinary russians
have stood up against this brutal war in
the streets of cities across russia from
saint petersburg to vladivostok
night after night they have flooded into
cities into city squares to call on the
government to withdraw their troops from
ukraine and leave its people in peace
these brave protesters have put their
freedom and their physical safety on the
line to say no to war and no to putin
the growing number of russians who are
bravely protesting against this
authoritarian government understand the
fundamental truth about this invasion
this is putin's war
to stop it we must act aggressively with
sanctions not only against vladimir
putin himself
but also the wealthy class of oligarchs
that put that support his rule over
russia
i strongly agree with the member from
burnaby south and experts like bill
browder that the only way to truly deter
them is by seizing the wealth they've
hoarded from russian people and stashed
abroad in tax haven tax havens and
luxury real estate
canada must immediately
expand our sanctions to target the
assets of russians ultra wealthy and act
decisively to ban their financial
transactions here in canada and across
the globe
we must ensure that putin's inner circle
are not able to hoard their wealth in
luxury real estates in canadian places
like vancouver and toronto
even after the invasion of ukraine
many oligarchs with well-documented
well-documented ties to putin's regime
are not the subject of magni sanctions
this must change and it must change now
but canada can't stop there
we must do everything in our power to
ensure that ukrainians fleeing this
horrific war find a safe haven here in
canada
even before putin's invasion ukraine was
already
facing a truly massive refugee crisis
according to the ministry of social
policy of ukraine approximately one and
a half million people were internally
displaced after fleeing the conflict in
dunbas and from russian occupied crimea
now thanks to russia's invasion there
are millions more refugees who are
fleeing russian airstrikes missile
attacks and military columns
they need our help
and they need it now
as the proud home to the largest
ukrainian dysphoria in the world
canada's canadians including my
constituents in edmonton griezma are
ready to step up
but the reality is the federal
government can do much more as well
despite years of calls from the
ukrainian community and the ndp
ukrainians still do not have visa-free
access to canada this must change
ensuring that ukrainians have visa free
access to canada is truly the bare
minimum
but ircc's response today at the foreign
affairs committee on the visa
requirements was not encouraging
when asked about the ukrainian visa
requirements director general of
immigration program guidance that ircc
said and i quote
we're gonna continue to look for ways as
the situation evolves to make that
facilitated but the ukrainian visa
requirement is not currently
under review
this is not acceptable the liberal
government needs to immediately remove
the ukrainian visa requirement while
putin was amassing troops in belarus and
on borders of ukraine my colleague and
member for edmonton strathcona and i
wrote to the minister of immigration
urging him to take action to prioritize
family reunification and to ensure that
ukrainians are not caught in the
years-long ircc backlog
ircc has been broken for years
now more than ever we need a massive
investment in human resources and
personnel to process the many people who
are fleeing wars and seeking safe haven
in canada
while we must act decisively to ensure
that ukrainians find refuge in canada in
the coming days and weeks we must not
also turn our backs on those who have
already been fleeing from wars in other
regions in particular i'm thinking of
the people of afghanistan
this house should not forget that fall
that the fall of kabul took place just
six just over six months ago
afghan people who fled the taliban are
extremely vulnerable and canada must
make sure that we have the resources to
help everyone who is fleeing conflict
i want to thank my honorable colleagues
from all parties in this house
what i've witnessed this evening has
been truly a pleasure to see when the
world needs canada this house is united
in doing what is right
although there is much work ahead i
remain hopeful that our unity here will
ensure ukraine's freedom
sovereignty and security
lastly it is in the spirit and hope of
unity
i want to share with this house what i
had experienced just three days ago
i stood at the alberta legislature with
ukrainians from across alberta
i had friends there ukrainian friends
like marnie from my community
who are in
pain but whose strength has shown
through these truly dark times
i heard the ukrainians national anthem
it touched my heart
and i was moved by the many who joined
in the beautiful harmony the song of a
people united and strong
as we all must be here in the coming
weeks
upon us fellow kin faith shall smile
once more
thank you madam speaker
questions and comments questions
the owner member for vancouver east
thank you very much madam speaker and i
want to thank my colleague the member
from edmonton uh giesbrecht for his um
speech
a very thoughtful speech and very
measured speech and a very passionate
speech like him in my riding of
vancouver east the association of united
ukrainian canadians the vancouver's
branch
also stands with the people of ukraine
and have been calling for a peaceful
resolution their heart bleeds for the
fact that their family and friends
are in this horrible situation
now canadians
the canadian government has taken action
uh with our allies
i'm wondering whether or not the member
thinks that the day will come
when there would be peaceful resolution
and for this violence to end
i remember for edmonton griezbaugh
thank you very much to my honorable
colleague for that question and i do
believe that
peace
is more of a process in many ways than
it is a goal we must continuously
protect and safeguard the principles
that make our society truly free and
democratic
we have to ensure that we can
protect those who are most vulnerable
and ensure that our country and our
society is protected and safeguarded
against true evil tyrants and oligarchs
like the ones we're seeing with putin
and his gang of thugs
we have a lot more work to do
and in terms of the work that happens
that has to happen at immigration
refugees and canadians i know that this
member from vancouver east and myself
will work hard as we can to ensure that
those fleeing conflict get to safety
thank you very much madam speaker
questions and comments you're a member
for selkirk interlake eastman well thank
you madam chair and i just want to thank
all the members today who have uh
participated in tonight's conversation
that wasn't much of a debate because
we're all standing in unity here with
ukraine and with one another
in the face of uh the the terrible
atrocities that are being committed by
vladimir putin in uh ukraine
and i do appreciate the member from
edmonton griezbach on pushing the issue
of making travel from ukraine to canada
visa free it's the same thing the
european union has done and we know the
european union is taking in massive
amounts of of ukrainian ukrainians who
are fleeing they don't have to apply for
refugee status to enter into the
european union so we need to one first
and foremost
you know establish our own visa heat
travel to canada for everyone that needs
to get out of harm's way in ukraine and
secondly is we need to support the
european union nations who are currently
housing and feeding those ukrainians who
have gotten uh to safety and left behind
their loved ones so i was wondering if
the member would like to elaborate on
that what type of humanitarian efforts
are going to be underway to support
those in the european union who are
dealing with the frontline trauma coming
across the border from ukraine
i remember for edmonton griezball
i
for that question and i truly want to
thank all members of this house for what
i found to be a truly uniting
discussion
in a time that our country truly needs
to see leadership we have many many
people across this globe that look to
canada
as a leader not just in peace and
security but also in our ability to
provide support to others the
humanitarian crisis that's happening and
unfolding in ukraine across europe right
now is truly tragic we need an entirety
of the globe's approach to ensure that
that level of human suffering
does not get worse it's up to each and
every one of us here and truly our
colleagues across the world and all free
and democratic societies to safeguard
that and to make sure we provide that
support that we don't simply measure our
actions by words but we measure them
truly by the people we support
and i'm confident with what i've heard
tonight from this house that we will
truly achieve that i want to thank that
that i'm a member again for his
steadfast commitment to ukraine and the
people of ukraine thank you very much
madam speaker
um
i want to thank my honourable colleague
for that very important question we have
to really seriously consider
the role that diplomacy can play and
whether or not russia is truly a country
that can
or is willing to negotiate and i think
that question is one that we have to
truly debate in this house and it's
still up for debate i think that there
are attempts especially after i seen
ukrainian officials meet with russian
officials i thought that was a hopeful
sign that diplomacy truly is still alive
however i remain very cautious and very
i'd say nervous for the actions that are
unfolding right now across
uh across
europe in particular with security in in
ukraine and i think that as tensions
continue to rise diplomacy will become
less and less of an option and when that
route is very clear that it's no longer
an option we must expel
the ambassador but to this point i do
believe there are still opportunities to
ensure that we have a discussion and
that russia has a moment to still prove
to us that they can in fact be reasoned
with thank you very much madam speaker
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
ukraine
i want to thank the honourable member
for his question and for really
highlighting the problem that exists
right now in the world we have a very
small group of people
oligarchs meaning they have tremendous
power and wealth controlling systems
across the globe not just in russia but
i do believe russia is one of the most
aggressive countries that has found and
manipulated ways to use capital and to
use that capital to create pain
and particularly hide that capital as
well what we're seeing across countries
all over the world is these safe havens
for this
terrible amount of wealth wealth that
truly goes into fueling
a war machine
that's what's happening right now is a
select few very wealthy people
are using their means to create harm to
murder innocent lives and to create
division across what was historically in
the last at least 75 years peaceful
europe
and what we're seeing
is the use of terrible capital that is
harbored even in canada right now in
places like real or certain places like
toronto or vancouver and real estate
where they've been able to harbor this
wealth
and we have roles to play in order to
target that wealth sanction those
individuals and truly bring them to
justice because this isn't a war against
the russian people this is a war against
tyrants like putin and the oligarchs
that support him and his efforts thank
you very much madam speaker
comments we have time for a brief
question
it being
11 52 pursuant to the order adopted
earlier today the committee will rise
uh
[Music]
you